Okay,
boom,
and we're live with joy ideas and Tj
English.
Uh,
Joey turned me onto you a long time ago.
Mr English.
Uh,
he gave me a copy of the westies right?
What year was that?
Ninety eight.
Ninety nine.
Long time ago.
He gave me that book.
It's fantastic.
Really fascinating stuff.
First Book I published wasn't really
westies yeah,
1990.
How'd you guys find out?
I'd be each other.
He wrote book
book.
A friend of mine turned me onto a book
name Havana Nocturne that was a small
book of fascinating read and I was just
blown away by him and I went to a party
one night and there was a literary
agent,
Stan and I go,
you fucking guys read the van like
during like an option that I was like,
that's fucking,
that's going to be a great book with
just,
uh,
it broke down the,
the uh,
how Fidel took over it from three
different cities,
how it was going down in three different
categories.
And then I heard that he was writing a
book about West New York and you city
Cubans where I grew up and I emailed him
and I told him who I was,
that my mother had a bar and I grew up
in that shit and he hit me back and we
became friends.
He came to a show and
yeah,
yeah.
Joe,
he reached out to me,
you know,
unfortunately when I was just about
finishing this book,
so I had done most of the work and it
was down on paper,
but it was a trip.
It was like he was,
he was like a character who walked out
of the book and I wished I'd met him
earlier because I hadn't met too many
characters like him.
You need city's amazing place.
I don't think people realize that it's
one of those little enclaves happens to
be Cuban.
It's like a Mafia neighborhood,
but it was Cubans,
not Italians or it was like hell's
kitchen,
which I wrote about in the Westies,
which was an Irish neighborhood,
very intense neighborhood.
A high premium on loyalty.
I'm young males running loyalty games on
each other all the time from the age of
six,
so we didn't know how far you'll go turn
this sucker up.
How far?
How far will you go for me?
Uh,
you know,
uh,
what are you willing to do for me in the
case of Hell's kitchen in the westies it
was cut up bodies was not only would you
kill somebody for me,
but will you make the potty disappear?
And they tested each other with,
with the cutting up of the bodies and
union city.
A lot of it was,
was political.
Some of it was political.
How antifa Idella you,
how badly do you want to kill,
you know,
Fidel and help us reclaim our last
homeland.
That was kind of behind a lot of things.
It wasn't spoken about a lot,
but it was sort of the hidden
motivation.
Westies was a really fantastic book.
Like you,
you went deep into that whole sort of
sub scene.
You know,
it's a,
it's a very interesting crime infested
area.
Well,
what,
what I try to do with these books is to
tell the macro story.
The larger historical sociopolitical
story and then get intimate and tell the
interpersonal stories between the
characters that actually lived this
story.
That's a challenge.
You've got to find people who are
willing to talk to you and share
information with you that they've kept
quiet probably most of their lives and
then you get at the interpersonal stuff
because these stories really are just
human beings caught up in something
that's bigger than them.
And how long when you,
when you're writing a book like the
corporation,
which is your new book or Westies are
any of your books,
how much time do you spend doing the
research and how much time do you spend
actually writing the book,
uh,
takes about three years to do these
books on average and an n two of those
years is research probably.
Wow.
Yeah.
So you do bring this to the Book
Company,
the publisher and you say,
Hey,
this is what I want to write a book.
You do a proposal and I do very,
very detailed proposals for the
corporation.
I did a proposal,
it was 125 pages long and it's a chapter
by chapter breakdown.
It's almost like a condensed version of
the book and you get more money from a
publisher that way as an advance because
you're showing them the whole thing
practically.
They can see the finished product
almost.
And also,
you know the movie interests.
There was movie interest in this one,
the corporation based on that,
on that proposal.
Interesting.
Yeah.
It was option to,
based on that proposal before I even
started writing the book.
Real.
Yeah.
So what is the corporation about the
corporation,
the story of the Cuban American
organized crime organization that began
in the mid 19 sixties and existed all
the way to the end of the century and it
was led by this mobster named Jose
Miguel battle,
who was kind of a legendary figure in
Cuban American circles because he was a
hero from the Bay of Pigs invasion.
The,
uh,
the attempt to reclaim Cuba take back
Cuba,
the invasion in 1961,
which was a disaster for everyone
involved,
battle wound up in prison along with the
rest of the brigade.
And when he got out and came back to the
US,
he was determined to get Castro and take
back Cuba.
So he set up this criminal thing and it
was based on a one racket primarily
Bolita the number,
the lottery,
the illegal lottery for the lottery was
illegal.
It was illegal and it was controlled by
organized crime.
And it was a huge moneymaker,
big money maker for the mob going back
to the 19 twenties.
Everyone.
That's the number of little old ladies,
but the number of priests,
cops,
you know,
you can bet a nickel,
you can bet a dime.
You can bet $10,000,
hugely profitable for whoever controls
and organizes it.
Well,
the Cubans controlled and organized it
on the eastern coast of the United
States from New Jersey and New York all
the way down to Miami.
And the guy who controlled it was battle
and he became legendary.
Based on that,
they controlled the whole number system
because I know there's a lot of Italians
that were involved.
They went to the Mafia.
One of the first things battle.
That battle had been a cop of ice cop in
Havana in the 19 fifties.
During the.
For the turnover.
Yeah.
During the era when the mob joey was
talking about Havana Nocturne.
That's what that book was about.
The era of the mob in Havana in the
fifties.
Meyer Lansky Santa traffic content and
how they controlled that until Castro
came along and spoiled the party and the
revolution happened and they got chased
out of their battle.
Had been a vice cop in Havana during
those years.
And he knew all those,
uh,
high ranking mobsters in effect.
He was a bag man who delivered money
from the Skimm at the casinos in Havana
to the presidential palace.
So battle knew how the world went round
and he made those connections.
And when he finally gets to the US and
wants to start his own thing,
first thing he does is go to Santa
Traffic.
Content says,
can you make the proper introductions
for me?
Profit content introduces him to fat
Tony Salerno in New York City who
controls the numbers racket for all five
families and battle says,
look,
things are changing in Cuba over the
next couple of decades.
You're going to have tens of thousands,
if not hundreds of thousands of Cubans
coming to live in the United States.
They all bet the number.
That's a huge market.
If you let me take over this thing and
organize it,
you will get a piece of,
you will get your piece of everything.
And the Mafia said yes.
And so the Cubans took over and they
control everything.
I mean,
in New York City in the seventies and
eighties,
there were probably 200 to 300 belita
spots where you could go bet the number.
That's the Cubans call it bullying a
little ball.
And uh,
so they controlled it and they took care
of the mafia and everybody was got fat
and happy for awhile until it turned bad
and they started killing each other.
Now,
when Joey,
when you heard about this book,
this is something that you were very
intimately involved in when you were a
kid.
Very,
you know,
I come on your show and I'll tell you,
there's 100 stories I could tell you
there's a thousand dollars I can't.
And when he told,
when I read the thesis for this book,
I just knew,
I just fucking know,
you know,
I grew up in numbers when I went to
Catholic school on Saturdays when I came
home on Fridays and Saturdays at the age
of Eight,
I was sent to different locations in the
city,
the bronx,
Brooklyn and I will make $50 going to
the errands,
running numbers.
Go tell this guy.
The first number of the day is to,
you know.
So I grew up in it.
I grew up in a house where the bookie
would call my mother by 3:00 and go,
what's the numbers for the day?
And My mother would give him a fucking
laundry list,
you know.
And uh,
it's very interesting in this book he
also covers the mysticism of the number.
So if I'm at your house and your
daughter walks in with a hockey shirt
and her number is 13,
I'll look at you and go,
Joe,
give me a number from zero to nine five
and pick up the phone.
I bet.
Five,
13.
If I look out my window and the cop cars
is five.
Oh six.
I put $5 on five or six.
If I have a dream about an eagle,
when I go down to the belief that spot,
there's books that they sell,
books or dreams.
And I take that book and I look up Eagle
Eagles number eight.
I pay eight.
13.
It's,
you know,
you,
you were mentioning a couple months ago
that your grandmother took numbers.
Grandmother was Sicilian.
Sicilian people have the same,
uh,
everyday they live today's today.
Yesterday's the day.
Joe Rohde.
Yup.
Today's the day.
I'm hitting the number.
I'm not getting.
You know,
she talks about that dream,
that dream.
Again,
we're going back with the immigrant
mentality.
But those three numbers today,
if God wants,
if God is real,
what he says,
it's true.
Might number's gonna come out today.
One is my ship going to come in that you
work a plain Jane dream you wrote,
you're a blue collar person and on the
way home,
every day by 3:30 you put the number and
that's it.
That's what you do.
Something to believe in.
Something believe in numerology and with
q and a.
It was very mystical.
It was tied into a dreams and belief.
The idea was you bet the number and you
try to make your dreams come true.
That's literally what you're doing.
You're trying to make your dreams come
true,
and the belief that guides the bullied
thoreau's the ones who control it there,
the dream makers,
they're the guys who are making it
possible for your dreams to come true.
So they had tremendous stature in the
community community.
Every dream solver.
So you work t j's Jose battle and you're
an independent booking.
Your job is to sit at a bar and lounge
in western New York from 10 to three
drinking and all day long people come in
and go,
Joe,
give me five slash 17,
$3.
Give me three.
Oh,
three one doll at 3:00,
3:30 a number comes up.
If that number wins,
if I give you $500,
you get $3,000 from battle.
You give me 2,500 so you make $500 off
the top.
And then I tip.
Yet,
the thing that battle did was he didn't
take 10 points.
He let you run your independent action
unless you called it in to him,
you know,
it's very,
you'll watch the movie.
Uh,
uh,
what's smooth Mickey Rourke and the
train these people a year,
the Dragon,
great fucking movie,
great movie.
When he says,
you know,
for years the Chinese will bring it into
heroin and they were selling it to the
Italians,
you know,
$50,000 investment to make you $500,000.
Chinese weren't saying that like they
weren't seeing that.
Why?
Because they didn't have,
they couldn't bring it out,
they couldn't sell it.
Black people and Spanish people bitch
slap them to death.
So the same thing happened with Bolita
Fat Tony Salerno knew that he had a big
thing coming with the Cubans.
The Cubans want to put a bedroom with
Cubans.
Hm.
Yeah.
Do you understand the Italians?
They want to put a bedroom with
Italians,
Puerto Ricans.
They want to put a better than with a
Puerto Rican.
It's not a big thing.
That was with the numbers.
It was that there was a community thing.
Let's talk about the numbers.
Like the lottery is some sort of a
government funded thing and it seems
like it's got a lot of red tape and
official and there's no wiggle room.
The,
the numbers seemed to be closer to like
the community,
especially with Latinos.
Especially with lucky.
Yeah.
It was the,
in some ways the core of the community,
the number of spots where everybody
would hang out.
You go to here,
the neighborhood lobola and the gossip
in the streets.
He'd go there and here in the
neighborhood gossip.
Uh,
yeah.
And,
and it was never meant to be violent
back in Cuba.
Belita was not violent.
It was illegal,
but it wasn't violent and it turned very
violent in the United States.
The corporation became so profitable.
I mean,
we're talking about millions of dollars
on a monthly basis,
billions of dollars over the course of
the life of this organization,
billions of dollars more than they
could.
The artist thing they had was what to do
with the money.
I mean,
they,
they would literally strap money to
people to as money couriers to try to
get it out of the country to get it into
getting into offshore bank accounts and
launder the money.
They had more money than they knew what
it was.
A license to print money,
which hugely profitable.
That's what made it violent.
Then you started having gangsters vying
for territory,
territorial disputes,
greed,
greed took over.
And it got very ugly nose.
This between Cubans,
between Cubans,
between the Cubans and the Italians.
See,
this guy battle was very charismatic
leader,
uh,
with some great leadership qualities.
He'd been a hero in the Bay of Pigs
invasion.
He saved some guys lives.
Um,
when I first heard that story,
I didn't.
I said,
I got to verify that maybe this is just
the story I got told about himself to
burnish his legend.
So I found the guys that he saved and I
found the guys,
two brothers who went with him to save
that,
the guys that he saved and I went to
Cuba,
to the Bay of pigs to the exact location
where he saved these guys to verify this
story.
And it was absolutely true.
He and in an act of incredible heroism,
he saved the life of a number of his
platoon members.
And so that was his reputation.
From then on,
he was revered in the community.
He was a hero and people defended him
even even when it turned ugly.
And he became a ruthless boss who was
killing people left and right.
He had his defenders because of his
legend as a hero in the community.
And so the power that he had.
But he also had this,
uh,
joey and I were talking about this
tubing tab.
This Latinos have this.
Everybody has it,
but Cubans have a desire for revenge.
This guy,
you know,
the Bay of Pigs invasion was an attempt
that revenge to get revenge against
Castro.
And they were humiliated by that
process.
And a lot of the guys from that
generation had an unfinished agenda for
revenge.
So if you wrong this guy battle in any
way he was going to get you,
even if it took years and years of
calculation.
I mean,
there are stories in the book about this
one guy who killed his brother named
Pilou.
He took,
it took nine years and 12 attempts
before they finally killed this guy
polluted.
They shot him in his hospital.
He was in the hospital,
they shot him,
had an assassin dressed up as a male
nurse and go into the hospital and shoot
him between the eyes because there had
been so many failed attempts.
They weren't going to fail this time.
And that's embattled for 12 years.
I took night and kissed his ass.
No,
never caught him.
no bank disappeared.
And I believe the assassin got killed
later because he was talking about it,
having done it.
And so battle had him killed.
Wow.
Yeah.
So that the revenge motive,
the revenge motive Kinda drove battle
off the deep end.
And uh,
somewhere along the line he broke bad,
so to speak.
I mean,
I don't know if he was ever good and had
to break bad,
but he started doing internal killings
that really had nothing to do about
business.
They're all about revenge.
Well,
this is a theme that happens a lot with
organized crime people.
Right?
It's like they just get a taste of
killing
people and it becomes easier and easier.
And then that was the thing about murder
machine,
right?
About Roy Demeo.
Yeah.
It just was killing people.
Nothing to it.
After awhile.
And that's another book you gave me.
I was reading all those books on the
road because I was auditioning for so
many Italian roles.
I never really knew the history of it,
so I was just trying to read all those
books just so when I went in I had an
idea of what these characters and who
they were.
I saw them growing up.
I saw these guys,
you know,
growing up,
I just didn't.
The interesting thing about this book
was talking to the Bay of Pacers that
they knew that they were coming,
like for dumb,
no common.
He put Bob wire or something and his
quarterly,
the soldiers all slashed their feet as
they were landing.
There was four battalions.
Uh,
I
think the 250,
you know what happened when they landed,
there were Klieg lights set up on the
beach.
Yeah.
They knew that.
They landed,
they flipped the lights on and it lit it
up like a movie set.
Right?
When these guys landed Jesus,
they got slaughtered,
and they felt they'd been betrayed by
Kennedy,
you know,
that they were supposed to be air cover
and the air cover never came.
And why was that?
Because Kennedy,
Kennedy always had this operation was
started by the Eisenhower
Administration.
And the CIA was a CIA operation.
Kennedy inherited it and he never
really.
He always had mixed feelings about it.
I mean,
it was illegal.
It was a,
uh,
an illegal secret,
covert operation and attempt to
overthrow a government.
It would have been seen as an illegal
activity,
the eyes of the world to do it.
So Kennedy was trying to do it so it
could be done in such a way that it
could never blow back on his
administration,
and so he,
he withheld air cover at a crucial point
in that,
in that war lasted three days and they
got slaughtered and they got in,
they got imprisoned and they had a lot
of resentment towards Kennedy.
I mean,
I go into the book though a little bit
about the Kennedy assassination and the
belief that a lot of that,
a handful of those Cubans may have been
involved in the Kennedy assassination
along with the Italians,
with the mob because they were working
hand in hand with the CIA.
Yeah.
That was one of the leading conspiracies
outside of the CIA killing him and even
the CIA killing him was a part of the
bay,
the Bay of pigs conspiracy and also the.
The idea that he wanted to disband the
CIA.
There was a really interesting article
recently.
There was dismissing almost every single
conspiracy theory about the Kennedy
assassination.
They said,
except the CIA one,
there's legitimate possibilities that
the CIO.
Well,
you can bet your ass that if the CIA was
involved in Cubans orange.
Now let me ask something in the book.
You speak about Fidel's Mr.
Yeah.
He got one with her at this particular
one.
Merita.
She had gone to New Orleans or the
Dallas.
My Retail Lorena.
This is very interesting,
notorious figure.
She had a child with him,
uh,
and had an abortion and didn't have the
child.
She got pregnant with Fidel.
In fact,
Castro admitted as much.
She got pregnant with Castro.
She had a,
she had an abortion and then the CIA
used her to try to assassinate Castro.
She had was supposed to slip him a pill
and she put it in her face cream and the
pill dissolves in her face cream and
that was the pill she was going to try
to slip to Castro her.
Her case agent was a guy named frank
sturgeous who wound up being one of the
Watergate burglars.
See the thing about Bay of pigs and the
Cubans,
the Bay of Pigs invasion is the key to
understanding the whole ladder part of
the 20th century politics in the United
States.
The Cold War,
because the alliance between the CIA and
the Cubans rears its head constantly
throughout the latter part of the 20th
century.
The Watergate burglary,
five out of seven of the burglars were
Cubans.
Bay of Pigs Veterans Day had been
recruited by a guy named Ed Howard Hunt.
CIA agent who was one of the
orchestrators of the Bay of pigs.
Invasion was also one of the people that
on his deathbed said that he was
involved in the assassination of
Kennedy.
Yes.
This.
So the CIA would come to these Cuban
exiles,
the militant exiles,
and they'd say,
go do this operation,
go do this burglary at the,
at the Watergate,
and then we go get fidel,
go do this assassination.
And then we go get fidel.
And the Cubans were always ready and
willing because it was all leading back
to getting.
It was all leading back to.
Did you ever see the images of what they
said was Ed Howard Hunt?
He was one of the people that was
arrested.
There was a series of,
um,
uh,
there was a bunch of guys that were
arrested that were on trains that were
calling them hobos were all very well
dressed,
right,
that were near where the grassy knoll
men on the grass.
Oh,
there's lots of rumors about that,
that Howard hunt was one of those men.
There was even a reference that Jose
Miguel battle was one of those men,
but that couldn't have been the case
because he was in the army at the time
of the US army.
Um,
no,
so,
so it's like a,
it's like a subterranean narrative that
runs through the latter part of the 20th
century,
the CIA and right wing elements in
American politics using the Cuban
Americans to do all kinds of dirty
covert deeds.
And we're talking about terrorist
activity.
Assassination of an ambassador from
Chile,
right in Washington DC blew up his car
because he was sympathetic to Castro.
A bomb planted on a Cuban,
a jetliner flying from Panama City to
advantage 73 people killed.
Innocent people occluding the fencing
team from Cuba.
Young people,
a dirty war,
a dirty war was waged by the anti-castro
underground,
uh,
in combination in partnership with the
CIA and this,
we know about it now because a lot of it
has been declassified and it's come out,
we didn't know about it at the time it
was taking place,
why they blow up the plane,
just an act of terrorism against Cuba to
uh,
to show them that it could be done to
instill fear and paranoia in the queue.
The,
the concept was to destabilize the Cuban
government so they'd be vulnerable and
then you could take them over.
So any,
any act against Cuba.
I mean asking why blow the plane would,
is asking like why fly planes into the
World Trade Center?
You know,
it was just a destructive act.
It's pretty amazing how resilient Castro
was.
I mean,
unbelievable.
The guy's 90 miles away from Miami and
just ran shit through the sixties,
the seventies,
the eighties,
the nineties into the 2000.
They say there was something like 632
known plots to over over the course of
four or five decades to kill category.
Incredible.
Six hundred and 32,
that's 101 ways to kill Fidel.
And he went to,
he got a little train in New York and
they're like,
are you fucking crazy?
And they checked the see the other
bullet proof vest anomalies.
Like,
no,
he took the train to you.
Went wow.
Like he's fucking nuts.
He was fucking nuts.
So,
so,
um,
what makes this,
this gangster story of the corporation
so interesting and different is this
political context,
the framework that all this shit was
taking place against the backdrop of
this desire to kill Castro and take
back,
take back the homeland and anyone who
was involved in that was seen as a hero
within the community.
Joey can tell you about that.
Union city,
New Jersey and Miami where the hotbeds
of the anti-castro movement.
There were,
where it was an organization in Union
city called Omega seven and there was
one in Miami called Alpha 66.
These were terror organizations,
secret organizations that existed to
plant bombs.
They would plant bombs at embassies in
the united,
you know,
in New York City.
They would put,
they would put bombs at Lincoln Center
when a,
when an orchestra from Cuba was making
an appearance,
they were trying to shut down any
relationship between the US and Cuba and
governments that were sympathetic to
Cuba.
They would,
they would do actions against them.
And this went on for like 40 years.
Man.
That's unbelievable.
You mentioned for dome the Seventies in
Union city,
like a joke.
It's not a joke.
Don't even don't even bring them up dog,
because you will get some mad now.
Was there any pro for Dell support
amongst Cubans?
There was and bad things would happen to
them.
Um,
in the United States and Cuba though.
What about in Cuba Pro Castro,
India.
Oh yeah,
sure.
I mean,
was it real or was it out of?
Fear is real.
It's real.
I mean,
I've been there numerous times,
you know,
the killing people made a choice,
uh,
and the revolution I believe would have
happened with or without Fidel Castro.
I'm the guy who was in power bi.
Tiesta had taken over the government and
the coup d'etat,
he wasn't elected,
so he was kind of a fraudulent president
and there was an ever since he got in,
people knew it was a fraudulent
president and there was attempts to try
to ouster him and that's why he was such
a dictator.
He knew they wanted the house to him,
so he used the military to repress any
kind of movement against him and it was
ugly and the people rose up against it.
That's what happened.
It wasn't so in my belief,
the revolution in Cuba happened for a
very legitimate reason.
After it happened in power,
it was revealed that Castro and Che
Guevara were communists.
He casta was very cagey about that.
During the revolution,
they never talked about Marxism and
being communists or any of that,
and in fact,
fidel came to union city,
came to the United States to raise money
for the revolution while it was going
on.
Got arrested.
My friend's mom,
the escalades,
says,
she says,
she still remembers taking the bus in
the morning in union city and Fidel's
welcome to underwhelm talking to you.
How you doing?
Susan,
what's going on?
Wow.
He got in a bar room room.
He got in a bar room argument in a union
city and he got arrested over what,
a probably politics.
I'm sure it was a political discussion.
Um,
so,
so then the revolution happened and,
and you know,
Cuba becomes a repressive communist
Stalinist dictatorship.
But a lot of Cubans,
the way they saw it as,
that was the choice they made to go with
Fidel.
He did have a,
I think the,
the,
uh,
popularity of the people following of
the people.
Some people are quite proud of Castro
standing up to the United States.
Cubans are very proud people and they
take a lot of pride in the fact that
even though there's so much hardship
there that um,
it's a choice they made to go in this
direction.
At least they have their,
their self pride,
uh,
which is more in the,
can be said in some ways about Puerto
Rico and Jamaica and Dominican Republic,
all these other countries in that region
that are just as poor as Cuba.
Um,
so he has his supporters.
He always had his support.
Obviously.
He also had his detractors even within
Cuba.
Um,
most of those people are the ones who
got on rafts and tried to leave the
island at great risk to themselves to do
anything to get out of there because
they realize fidel was so popular from
within the country.
You are never gonna be able to take him
down.
So they made the decision to go out in
the ocean and try to brave the risks of,
of either swimming or sailing or across
the Florida Straits,
what the fuck happened with Che Guevara.
How did Che Guevara all of a sudden
emerge as this leftist political icon,
but in this really weird sort of
clueless way.
Like they really didn't understand his
background,
really didn't understand who he was and
what he had done and the atrocities that
he had committed.
But these fucking tee shirts that all
these dopey liberal kids,
those fucking things.
That's fucking crazy.
If you find out who that guy is,
your,
you're wearing a mass murderers t shirt,
like he was a fucking ruthless cut.
And these people are wearing this shirt
is if he symbols symbolizes like liberty
or freedom from an oppressive government
or something like that.
It's.
But it was a long period of time where
you didn't have any Che Guevara.
There was no discussion of it and that
it seems like somewhere in the two
thousands it picked up.
Am I right?
Yeah.
Eight.
Let me tell you something.
It was so personal for awhile.
Like I have Argentinian friends,
but in the seventies there was a rift
between Argentenians in Cuba.
That's how personal it is.
Argentinians is Argentina and there was
a rift like because of him,
because of him like Cuban.
Is the FEC data here really welcomed
that extra the fuck?
What is that?
They talk how they talk to Phillip?
Yeah.
What humans would go off and union city
of you were Argentinian really?
That's how deep age and read Cuban
Spanish.
How did the list thing,
where did that come from?
Why?
I don't know.
It's just a regional,
regional thing and they.
They're the number one on the top.
Like if a,
if a Cuban what?
Look.
Look at Cuba's,
the is considered the that were the Jews
of the Caribbean,
but Spain as one old,
like people,
like my father's family was from Spain
and I went there one time and never went
back.
Really get one time to meet my
grandmother.
Never went back.
Why?
Because she was talking shit.
No one at five talk to me.
That shit about my mother got me hooked
up to my mother.
She Spain is the colonial powers,
the colonial often,
often Spaniard to look down on the
Cubans and Mexicans I'm sure as well.
So I went over there one time.
My mom took me to meet my grandmother in
like 10 minutes and would call my
mother,
you fucking cunt.
My mother came over and goes,
what happened and what this fucking
bitch is talking about.
She was about five.
My mother cursed her out.
My relationship.
She was like,
my father was,
your father is going to be at that
because she was from Cama way so that
shit didn't stink.
My mom was a peasant from Havana,
so she was at.
My son had big dreams until he met your,
your that animal.
Fuck you.
You fucking like she made my mother
moved in with him in Cuba.
They learn how to cook the dishes.
Cc'd Spaniard would be offended.
Just by the way Cubans speak Spanish.
Yes,
but really like a lot of people tortured
me when they did the.
I don't speak Cuban Spanish.
I speak.
I speak the Spanish or the streets.
That Spanish.
I picked up in union city that streets
by.
Let me stop me now when I'm on.
Huh?
Anybody that gave you a hard time about
translating.
This is what I always tell people.
I'll talk in English.
Repeat what I said.
Good luck in English.
Yeah,
it's fucking hard.
It's hard to remember what someone said.
Especially Yoga was speaking to these
long sentences and you were translate.
You did a great job,
but my Spanish is.
Instead of giving me $5,
I want to mold a mold.
That means or none.
We don't say nothing because in my world
attend spot is a.
I forget what it is.
There's a name for it.
Yeah,
for everything.
I learned how to speak Spanish and code
a peeler.
That means keep your eyes open and put
your batteries in your.
When I say to you,
that means you got to put your batteries
in.
So I learned that street.
Is this a Bergen County street thing?
No,
no,
no.
This is Hudson county.
It's a Cuban.
I word my.
Yeah,
but it INA,
we talking Cubans in the US or like when
I talk,
when I talked to my sister on the phone,
I have no idea what you said.
Really.
Like when she gives me an address and
shit.
Anyway,
the ours and all that.
I took Italian in high school.
I didn't take basic Spanish.
I learned how to read Spanish in the
house by reading different things,
but I learned how to speak Spanish.
Like I remember going as a Cuban
person's house once and you didn't city
when I was about 12 and they told their
son,
don't bring this kid over here.
He's a street fucking SPEC.
St's back.
I learned.
I'll say they get on a long time though.
I didn't learn that traditional Spanish.
My Spanish is a lot of hands.
Segment was oil.
I see.
I see the people,
that means watch him,
watch him and don't fucking not watch
them a lot.
It's a lot of street shit.
I was never allowed to walk home the
same way.
You had to walk on different directions,
different directions to keep the car.
Don't,
don't put it in my mother's operation.
I could never just walk home on Burger
line to walk to New York Avenue.
We'll walk down just to see if I saw a
suspicious car.
Now.
That's smart.
Were you remembering?
You remember?
We were in San Francisco about 15 years
ago and we had the Cru,
tate,
Eddie,
uh,
you may Red Duncan and Redman will
walking down the street in San
Francisco.
As we approached and I saw a drug deal
go down.
I hit already going.
I already look at that drug.
Do you guys were looking at the whole
thing?
Not One of you saw it already goes.
How the fuck did you see that?
Because I was raised like that.
I was raised to go out and look for
cars.
I was never allowed to walk home the
same way twice.
Yeah.
Because of the lead the business.
Now,
let me ask you about that because w,
is this an instinct you learned on your
own or were you actually.
I was.
When I became a numbers runner,
as a child,
I was always.
My mom would put a.
When I was a kid and I came from Cuba,
my mother put up a big gold chain on me.
You know why?
Because she did you to take it off my
sheet.
My mother wanted you to take that chance
so I wouldn't have to fight.
Really?
Yeah,
so I remember one time Mr. softy.
He came and he looked at my goal thing
and my mother yelled from the window,
don't let them touch your fucking chain.
Yesterday I went to Glendale and my
daughter was throwing hoops hoop and she
was chasing them all four of them by
herself.
She's an only child,
so it was other kids there and the red
hoop fell through the thing and some 60
year old took it from that.
My daughter went to put her head down.
I go,
Oh yeah,
go take it back.
Go take it back.
And she just looked at me and the parent
was like,
that's an effective way of parenting.
She got back from your daughter.
Don't ever stay hitting my fucking
house.
Wait a minute though.
The mom of the kid that took it was
giving you shit.
Oh yeah.
Because this is today's America,
my America.
We don't come home at what did.
What did the mom wants you to do?
Mom and the dad to Glendale fucking
gentiles.
The Dad said,
that's an effective way of of whatever
box saying nothing bitch.
Your daughter.
A couple of weeks ago,
a little girl took the swing from my
daughter.
Take the swing back.
My wife's like,
what are you doing?
That's how Cubans raised their kids.
I was raised to always have my eyes open
because I knew what they did.
I was at a young age if I hung out with
Joe Rogan,
Joe Rogan's dad,
so coke.
I knew Joe Rogan's Dad.
So Coke Jolen.
What?
I would never tell you.
I came from a house where it was.
Yeah,
right.
But you know,
here's the thing.
If a.
If they wanted to get at your mother,
they had come after the kid.
Yeah,
they come in.
It was very common.
Again,
kidnapped the kid.
That's how you.
That's how you got to somebody.
Well,
that's how you get to everybody
mean this is a.
This trump thing was stormy daniels.
Do you see?
One of the things that she said that one
of the reasons why she came a lot about
this.
Somebody came up to her in a parking lot
when she was holding her infant
daughter.
I don't know if this is true.
This is what she says.
Someone came up to her and said,
you have a beautiful daughter.
It'd be a shame if anything happened to
her mother.
Now stop talking about president trump
wasn't president trump at the time.
Stop talking about Mr Trump,
and she was like,
oh,
fuck you.
Or fuck this,
and then you know.
Then she really,
really geared up or animosity towards
them.
Imagine that Shit.
Hey,
in the narco world,
there's cases of what they would do is
they will do a video tape.
There was somebody they wanted to
intimidate.
They'd videotape their kid being taken
to school every morning,
being dropped off for school,
picked up after school.
They videotape the daily routine of the
child and then they'd send the video
tape to that person and I,
I need to
know where your kid is every,
every minute of the day.
Do what we tell you to do.
He doesn't fuck with me though.
I was never fucked with.
I was never really a and a no,
no.
I was never fucked with.
I was just raised to understand what
they were doing it.
There's consequences and I was allowed
to repeat it.
So when I would come to you and you will
be talking about whatever.
Even if I knew you were wrong,
I would never correct you.
So that's how I was raised.
He would if I knew you were talking shit
because how do you know?
How do I know?
I was just at the fucking bar and they
were talking about I tried to fuck.
I know my mom didn't hide nothing from
me growing up.
That's good and bad that it had good
things for me,
but a lot of bad things to me,
you know,
one of the things that he touched upon
this book was not only about Jose
battle,
but the political corruption that came
with it in 20 years.
Have I ever talked to you about bottling
things to ever.
I wouldn't listen to politics if you
paid me because it's all bullshit.
I saw it and I and a micro level,
you know when you,
when you a president who do you get
donations from?
Big Farm guns,
whatever.
When you're a small mayor who they get
donations from the pharmacy,
the pizza place,
the numbers.
So I came from a society where those
numbers are controlling everything and
in North Bergen,
union city and West New York,
and we remember that Shit's a felony in
Jersey misdemeanor in New York.
Really?
Numbers.
It used to be misdemeanor.
As a matter of fact,
they would call you never go Joe
Lieutenant.
We wouldn't say that because the phones
would take.
He would just call you and go,
you're getting a visit today.
That means if you've got $5,000 in your
pocket and give it to Jamie,
cleaned out the house,
leave some paperwork at 2:00,
I come,
I handcuff you,
I take your money,
I write your summons and bring it down
to the station.
We get go.
And then after I let you,
how did I meet you around the corner?
You had $2,500.
I'll give you 1250 [inaudible] and
that's a cost of doing business.
You know,
there's a funny line in Goodfellas when
he goes,
how can I go to school with all that
goody,
goody bullshit and salute the flag.
When I left,
I was the same one.
Like I saw what happened.
I saw the political system.
I saw two cops coming in,
one detective once a week and one big
guy.
My mom would give him a drink and an
envelope.
Yeah.
I don't know what my grandmother did,
what she was involved,
but I told her she went to jail,
the jail for running the numbers.
She went to jail because she wouldn't
give anybody up.
They wanted her to give up.
Whoever the fuck was at the other end of
the organization,
and so for like six months we were
always trying to like,
where the fuck is grandma still all
she's visiting her sister who was
always.
She's visiting Aunt Josie and just
knowing for bookmaking
and Jersey six,
five months,
right.
Then they put you on house arrest and
you had done.
She would knit sweaters and shit for the
fucking guards in jail.
Well,
a lot of times battle would own the
judges.
So you wouldn't do any time,
you might get it,
you might get a summons,
you go before a magistrate judge and
they let you go.
What's fascinating to me is about,
this is all so fascinating about the job
itself was that a lot of it is basically
dissolved that all this came from
immigration and that this,
uh,
this melting pot of the United States
and they all came from all these other
places and all this organized crime sort
of like was running the,
the cities in the east coast.
But most of it is kind of gone the
wayside.
I would dispute that a little bit.
I think traditional organized crime,
as we knew it in the 20th centuries,
gone by the wayside,
Italian,
Irish,
Jewish,
that sort of assimilated into the system
and has dissipated,
but there's new generations,
immigrants that are playing this out,
Jamaicans to make Americans,
Chinese,
Russians,
Mexicans.
It's happening.
And I further make the argument that the
corruption that was created during
prohibition in the 19 twenties,
that's where the system was created
during prohibition in the 19 twenties,
the,
uh,
alliance between the underworld and the
upper world,
the connection between the political
apparatus,
law enforcement and the criminal
rackets.
That template was laid down during
prohibition and it was an effect for the
next 100 years.
I think that templates still exists.
You pick up a newspaper in any US city,
large or mid sized city.
And what are you going to see on the
first couple of pages,
some local representative who just got
indicted for taking money from some
criminal element to see that they got a
law passed or that they got some
municipal contract.
Uh,
that hasn't gone away.
That still exists everywhere.
What happens is there's an ebb and flow.
Certain rackets come and go,
it was illegal booze and it was labor
racketeering.
Now it's narcotics.
It was Belita at one time.
There's always something,
you know,
as long as there's commerce being done
on a large scale,
there's always room for corruption as
long as there's things that are illegal
with this market for like marijuana
argument.
Yeah,
right.
The big argument about marijuana laws,
the United States is if they made it
legal,
it would severely limit the power to the
cartel in Mexico has cut all that
violence out.
Basically the same shit that was going
on with Al Capone and,
and everything during the liquor there.
Time with liquids.
Yeah.
Because the criminal rackets feed the
system.
Human beings are flawed human beings at
every level of the system.
Dirty cops,
cops on the take.
I mean,
is it more difficult now for them to
pull something like this off?
It's less systemic,
you know what I mean?
I mean,
back in the day,
you know,
uh,
you'd have corruption that was all the
way through the chain of command,
you know,
and everyone was sort of in on it.
Now you see the seven five.
Yes,
I did.
I also saw your interview with Michael
Dell.
Fascinating.
Yeah,
that was fascinating.
Um,
yeah,
I mean he,
he,
and that was 20 years after the nap nap
commission which revealed that level of
corruption.
Um,
yeah,
no,
see there's,
you have social systems and you will
have corruption.
You have a money making system like
capitalism,
you will have corruption that doesn't go
away.
Organized crime has the face of
organized crime has changed quite a bit,
but the core of,
of that corrupt relationship between the
underworld and the upper world still
exists.
So is it the most disenfranchised sort
of members of the community,
the most recent immigrants?
Like what,
what is it that.
Yeah,
I've written about this a lot,
you know,
two different books and through
journalism I've come to believe that
it's the American story.
This process of going through organized
crime and gangsterism before you become
accepted as a full blown American.
Um,
every,
almost every ethnic group has gone
through some version of it in the US and
it's still an is still going through it.
It's part of the American process.
You get here as a group,
your your cutout of access,
a immediate access anyway to to power
and so you create your own path and
initially in these organizations it's
usually those ethnic groups praying on
their own,
preying on each other.
That's usually the first stage of this
and then it becomes a creating a system
to try to deal with larger system of
corruption.
I mean Jose Miguel battle.
What he did was so brilliant by creating
the corporation is he created a path for
himself within American organized crime
which was controlled primarily by the
mafia and he created an alliance with
the mafia that made it possible for the
Cubans to have their thing and and fly
below the radar.
I mean while he Italians were getting
busted left and right.
The Cubans,
the Cubans.
This corporation existed for 40 years
because they didn't really get messed
with with
much.
Why is that like what was it the.
The way the Italians there were so
flashy,
like particularly when you got the God
he was the most ridiculous,
were pretty damn flashy too.
Some of them.
Some of this,
some of them I,
I till this day I detest nice cars.
I had the test show calling attention to
yourself because I saw too tight,
like right now,
like I would love to talk to the
producers of this film because they're
going to miss a lot of authentic stuff.
I'm sure that we'll have.
In fact,
I have a present for you.
I ordered you the same shirt,
Bruce Lee,
war and fist of fury.
They called.
Cami said,
that's Chine US Cubans.
When you,
when you were a success memo and Tony
goes into see his mother Mama success.
I,
I read that like gastro.
When you become a success in union city,
the Chinese tee is your first sign of
success because it has three buttons
here,
right?
So you cut the buttons off and young.
What's your middle name?
James.
So it's Joseph James Rogan in diamond
initials.
You putj j dot and that's when you've
reached success and they need that.
They,
they,
that's part of their,
you know,
like there's so many little things that
Cubans did,
but taken down like one for example,
my stepfather.
Brilliant,
brilliant.
You know Paulie didn't talk on the
phone.
Well move for anybody.
Paul,
he had his message is delivered.
Then in 1970,
I'm looking at both of you gentlemen and
I'm telling you that one would not even
have a conversation if there was a phone
in the room and it was hung up because
in his mind that phone was fucking
tapped,
right?
He was a genius.
If he had a meet Joe Rogan for a meeting
at nine at 5:30 in the morning,
he'd come and put a gun under a car just
in case there was a problem with Joe
Rogan.
He will hug you and you searched him.
He would hug you and tap your back for a
wire and tell you you will lose some
weight and rub your belly at all.
Then they hug you,
but that feeling you for a pink one.
When my mother died,
he still had the same car that he had
when he died with $5 million cash and he
lived in a four story walk up.
When he died,
one of his friends said,
what a miserable life to make money and
have to hide it like that one would walk
around with jeans and t shirts the same
shit every day.
And a wad of hundreds like this.
The hidden one.
The other one was single.
So you thought he was broke.
If he talked to you,
he talked to you in English.
Once the cops came.
Me.
No biggie.
You know,
who was the interpreter for all the
attorney meetings where all those high
level guys.
Me Really?
So I'd be at school,
I'd be at home when my mom would go
tomorrow you have to go with child to
the Lucas Office.
Sam,
they'll Luca and Sam.
The local will look at you and go,
I don't Joe,
great to see you today.
You'd have to bring him a suit.
He loves suit Sam de Luca.
So the more suits you brought them,
the better.
He was like the other guy,
the guy that had the thing,
but Sam would treat you just like this
Joe Rogan.
We ain't okay.
You're going to interpret.
This was how fast the conversation was.
You got busted for conspiracy of
bookmaking.
That's two years listening to this
judge.
She's a motherfucker,
but thank God I know the
prosecutor.
So Day one I'm going to do for $300,000.
We lose the episodes for 200,000 a year
for 100,000.
You get probation and you do a year and
a half way house for 50,000.
He just gives you a menu when you decide
what you want to do,
get back to me.
Always a pleasure to see you and you had
a week to decide what you were going to
do.
Wow.
So you gave him that amount.
He knew his way through the court
system.
You didn't do no time.
There's no time.
I know for a fact that if you get caught
with a gun to New York,
you get.
What's the law?
He.
Yeah,
there was some mandatory mandatory.
There's no goal.
There's no trial and take you right to
my stepfather.
Wong got caught with a gun.
He was under the next day.
The Lucas don't play game Deluca.
Don't play games now.
Now and answer Joe and answer to your
question about the Cubans and why they
existed for so long and didn't get
busted,
you know,
the rumor was that they had a certain
mystique because of this CIA,
a pedigree and that they were
untouchable and in factor.
I mentioned it in the book,
there's a case where the FBI is thinking
about making a case against battle.
This is way back in the sixties.
They contact the US Treasury Department
because they figure he's not paying
taxes and they can make some kind of
case against him and a tax violation.
They got a letter from the Treasury
Department saying,
we're not going to go after this guy
because he's anti-castro and he's a
veteran of the Bay of pigs invasion.
It's right there in a,
in a,
in a letter from the Treasury Department
to the FBI.
Wow.
So there were elements within the
government that we're protecting these
guys,
particularly bay of Pigs veterans.
We will not prosecute them.
That's incredible.
And so he had that kind of protection
with a name too,
Huh?
Jose battle bottling.
Yeah.
His name is Spanish.
Was bothy a bat l,
l e,
and he changed it to balance a good one,
right?
If you're,
if you're a writer and a novelist and
you're trying to think of a good name
for the character that she can't do any
better than.
I grew up with a kid named major battle
God to taekwondo.
His name was major battle.
That motherfucker too bad.
Motherfucker named major battle was his
middle name.
Bad mother fucker.
Major bad mother.
But it was.
It was a black belt state champion and
the only reason why they existed,
they were very careful.
They have a systemized union city,
Ran Union city becomes Jersey City and
hoboken you didn't see ran seventh
street to 88th street to white castle,
but the Cubans really controlled seven
to 48th street Bergen line.
And then when you went to New York
Avenue,
they control from $50 up to about 60th
street and they kept to themselves and
they didn't have social clubs and it
didn't play cards outside.
And if you want them to the bar,
they wore dress very,
moderately before.
From what?
Bookies.
And they only stayed there till 3:00
because that's when the number goes in,
so you have from nine in the morning to
three to play that number.
But there's also a thing called a
singular number,
which the odds are a little less.
That started about 12.
So I'll see you at 12 and go for it.
Normal it.
Make a mother fucker.
I'll never listened to that fucking kid
of mine again.
Now I got to go back to the booking and
bet the second number,
call that.
That's one number at a time.
So I have an optimization putting down
$100,000 on,
on what the number five is.
What is the number of year,
the potential numbers talking single
digits on.
I can play three digit.
Read that.
You Bet.
Three digit.
So why would it be a single number?
Well,
that was just a different one.
A different one.
Different systems,
different systems.
Certain ways you can do it.
But let's explain this where the number
comes from.
Okay.
The total mutual handle at the race
track is published in the newspaper
every evening and again and again in the
morning.
How much money was bet total at the race
track that day?
The last three numbers.
That's the daily number.
So everyone you know has the same number
for everybody.
You know what it is as soon as it comes
out in the newspaper and that's how it's
determined.
So you have,
you have the individual numbers and then
you have the early number with which is
called welcome come out of Brooklyn,
guest Saleo in Brooklyn and then you
will have the late number.
What's The New York number?
That's number in the New York number
side.
Like what it would be based on that was
decided probably a hundred years ago by
some by some,
you know a Guinea who ran,
who ran it for the Italians and maybe it
came from Sicily.
Whatever.
The origins of it.
You couldn't have fixed that though.
It's like it's gambling so it can't fix
it.
Why isn't it?
Because it's the.
I don't know what the track is going to
make that.
Fix that.
How would you say you fixed the last
three numbers?
Checked this out.
Certain organizations like the
corporation,
part of the reason people wanted to bet
with them and like to bet with them is
they would have somebody at the race
track,
so the minute that number was posted,
they'd know the number.
So you'd get your,
you didn't have to wait around for a
newspaper or for sports,
you had to call sports.
Uh,
nobody remembers that.
You remember that Tj,
how are you doing?
Welcome.
This is Joe Rogan.
You just called sports live.
You've got to sit by a payphone and put
thirty five cents and they would run all
right that,
that child and after the scores and they
give you the score,
but whatever.
You Bet.
What's the last fucking thing?
Oh,
so you had to sit there and take that
whole.
We have beat mother fucker.
Give it to me.
And then when it came to them saying the
number,
the subway go by and
you're just lost another thirty five
cents.
But the whole number system,
like my mother was a degenerate numbers
and then she will kill the,
with the Yankees and the red sox later
on.
But her game was the numbers,
the three numbers didn't do your track
and now let's get greedy.
Why don't we go to Otb?
Yeah.
Now see this is where.
Why don't we just go to old beat a
really complete your fucking day?
You degenerate the brilliance of battle.
And his organization was,
he didn't do sports betting and in fact
his arrangement with the Italians,
with the mafia was you get Belita,
you get numbers,
but you don't get sports betting and you
don't get these other things.
And so there was a.
there's an.
There's an example in this book of a,
of a member of the corporation who
starts against battles.
Wishes starts playing,
doing sports,
betting at that guy wound up dead.
A battle killed himself because he was
going against the agreement going
against the rule,
going against the rules that could turn
them off against them and bring the
whole thing down.
Right,
right.
Wow,
that's amazing.
Now and answer your question about how,
how they came up with that number.
You got to remember,
it's all gambling.
This is the culture of gambling.
You know,
you're at the race,
track,
your bedding card games,
you're bedding petting the number,
so it's logical that somewhere in that
universe would be how the number was
determined.
So it came from the race track and then
you also have the Puerto Rican lottery
and that comes and paperwork.
It's different.
That's completely different.
Paperwork,
paperwork,
paperwork that comes a lottery tickets.
My mother would buy the whole fucking
sheet.
It's like $10 a thing,
but you could just buy the sheet.
And what is it?
It's a Puerto Rican.
Them now you know that the corporation
use the Puerto Rican lottery to launder
their profits.
Yeah.
So you hit the number.
You're my friend.
What are you gonna win 20,000 by the
time they give it to you.
Let me just give you 18.
Do you know that's how Whitey bulger
laundered money,
right?
That's how Sammy the bull one lottery
tickets to Whitey bulger won the lottery
twice.
Twice.
People.
The neighborhood won the lottery and he
bought the ticket from them,
gave him money or whatever the fuck he
gave him.
Check this one out.
Today's paper.
A front page of USA Today,
confessions of a lottery scammer.
I brought this along.
I taught if he interest lottery scam.
This is a guy,
big fat guy,
trainer pounds sitting on his ass in
Iowa or somewhere who was on his device
who figured out some way to intrude on
some algorithm and he started scamming
different states.
He scammed the state of Colorado out of
four point $8 million dollars.
And uh,
there is uh,
a total of 16 point five.
Boy,
you guys are good.
A 16 point $5 million.
I'm now I'm thinking if this guy had
scammed the corporation led by Jose
Miguel battle,
he,
he'd be,
he'd be dead.
He wouldn't be on the be beyond the
obituary section.
Look what it says here was never my
intent to start a full out ticket scam.
Yeah,
yeah.
His sentence up to 25 years old years
old.
Not Scam,
organized crime in this way.
How do you skim lottery?
Like you figure out,
you figure out how the number is
determined and then you're able to play
with it.
You're able to play with it.
See,
in organized crime,
you couldn't do understand that.
How could he like,
isn't there just a random system,
a computer program or something?
Yeah.
He found some way to,
to,
uh,
to tap into that computer system to tap
onto me to hack into a hack into it and
can alter the number.
Oh,
wow.
That's crazy.
Wow.
That is crazy.
What is fascinating to me is this,
what you were talking about earlier when
we're talking about,
about like that this was,
it gave them an opportunity for hope and
that it was a part of the community.
We're missing that in the west coast,
the west coast,
like offtrack,
betting.
There's no fucking here.
There's a few Weirdos that go to the
Hollywood park,
but that's gone now.
You know what I mean?
There's nothing in the west coast.
Never had this,
does nothing.
Yeah.
There's nothing like seeing that.
Like,
I saw that and I saw what goes with it
and it may sound he spoke it in most
people,
but it's not who you spoke to.
The people who are really,
really Sicilian people who are normal
Cuban.
When you're a Sicilian in that culture,
there's women that you go to them,
they tell you things that witches,
the Sicilian witches,
whatever the fuck you want to and
sleepers remember,
he goes,
bring the eyeballs.
So this lady,
what sleeper sleepers is a movie about
for Irish kids that lay there was
bullshit because of a woman.
You remember that movie?
It's about the four kids narrow place.
A priest,
priest,
but a Brad Pitt grandson.
Okay.
There it is.
Barry Levinson movies.
Then they got the guy on the leather
men.
Then he started backtracking like Steven
Seagal by the CIA involvement.
Lorenzo Carter.
He later on became.
It was a true story and it was not a
story.
It was based.
But uh,
if you look at it one,
two for those two kids were supposed to
grow up to be west.
Yeah.
But it wasn't bullshit.
It's bullshit.
Like they,
the two other,
the four of those guys.
What are we talking about?
Talking about?
Well,
you were talking dollar witches.
He,
you know,
in the Cuban world,
it's the same thing.
I want my kid to go to Catholic school,
right?
If I play this fucking number today,
this is gonna.
Save me.
We,
you know,
we don't.
When you're a comic you have that hope
tonight I'm going to go to the Improv.
Just Sasha was going to be that.
Maybe you know,
just made it.
It's a,
but it's an ethnic hope that comes back
from your country.
It's hard to describe.
You understand that because your
grandmother was a fucking booky.
But if you talked to her on a daily
basis about it and why she would play
that particular number.
Like my mom played five slash 17.
Those are the last three numbers on my
dad's gravestone,
you know,
604 with some other fucking
hallucinogenic.
She had.
If I go like this,
if I go like this and I go,
you know what,
you're looking good today and they'll
take a yard stick.
Most Cuban is look at it and go give me
$5 on to fifth grade because it's the
last three numbers of 20.
You fucking gave me.
Now is this still going on?
Oh yeah.
The numbers are still going on.
Not In a,
not as a,
not as a 10 minute head office.
When I was a kid it was a 10 man office.
You went downstairs,
you had a bodega,
me and you ran the Bodega is use and
yesterday's paper always selling the
book of dreams and then you come in and
you give me six.
Oh,
four slash five slash 17.
It's comes on three sheets of paper with
with copy paper.
So right away I ripped the top one.
I give it to you.
I keep the other one and the other one
goes upstairs to the department where
now there's a big wall with zero to nine
on the wall and I parked that.
So Joe just came up and played 2:19.
There's two and all of a sudden there's
a list that goes down.
I'm a board guy.
I just worked the board.
I got six guys with phones yelling
numbers on me.
Oh Hey.
At rogen fucking just put $100 and that
number,
that motherfucker killed me last week
sometime send $50 of that to Miami
because I got unloaded to create the
Utopia.
You know when you.
When I take a sports,
but I'm taking $500 on Pittsburgh,
Pittsburgh's plain New England.
I can't take 10,000 on Pittsburgh and
$5,000 New England.
That's not called a utopia.
I'm going to make money on the vig.
The 10 points from you losing.
So if you bet 10,000 on somebody and you
bet five.
I unload five a to another bank
somewhere across town.
So this is how an.
I mean when I was a kid,
my mother had a bank in the Bronx and
the guy that cooked was black Mike.
He was a Vietnam vet and I was five and
he would give me 10 bucks to go get
them.
Blackberry,
brandy black.
Mike cooked Italian food.
That was so fucking good.
It was 1970.
Even if you hate a black we,
you waited his spaghetti.
Even Italians came to eat his spaghetti
on Wednesdays.
He could corn beef on Wednesdays.
He made Cuban food.
They have an office and every phone has
a little tape recorder with a wire
connected to the phone.
So you can't call me and say you played
two eight.
Yeah,
it's recorded.
Fucking busted your way to tape for you.
So every hour the tapes come around the
same and those get destroyed the week
after or that night after everything
settled,
but the CEO's offices in action when
you're a kid and I'm going to get
cigarettes
and they'd give me a 10 to go get a
three donald pack of cigarettes.
I keep seven now.
Did you ever see the money?
What do you mean?
The moral of the money that was
gathered?
I saw how the money would be taken to a
separate location.
I will be a separate location room now.
There's also they move locations every
week.
You also have to stay ahead of the cops.
So every week you got a guy like Joe
Rogan that just rents apartments woman.
So every week we moved locations so
nobody ever gets comfortable with three
months at one place than what?
Three months in another place.
Then what?
Three months in the other place,
because not only will you have to worry
about cops,
you got to worry about Jamie getting a
little fucking cocky.
Jamie found out from Joe does that they
make $40,000 a day,
Jamie's two guns,
two guns and try to go up there and see
what happens because they got two guys
on the third floor that just got two
guns waiting for idiots like you to come
upstairs to the fourth floor.
It was surreal.
So in the morning is my mom would go,
you want to go to school or you want to
color match and go,
yeah,
I go,
I'm going with you because he's bookies
will all give me 20,
40 bucks.
It's part of that good.
Now check this out.
At the end of the day,
every day that this is going on there,
because betting is going at every day,
seven days a week and the system that
joy's talking about,
so money's coming in,
a lot of money's coming in.
It goes to the accounting rooms,
so at the end of the day you got a lot
of money and like two,
300 different locations all around the
New York area.
What they would do is they have people
whose responsibility it was to come
around and collect the money.
That money would go into a van and that
van would have a police escort as it
left New York City went through the
tunnel and in New Jersey it was met by
New Jersey police who picked it up and
escorted from there into the apartments
or the houses in union city where the
money was crazy.
Wow.
So the cops got paid.
So how can I tell you this?
At the age of 10,
I knew this,
but I could never tell.
You wouldn't believe me,
so I had to keep it to myself.
Well,
most of the kids wouldn't be able to
shut the fuck up.
I was talking about not the corner I see
in my world.
I didn't win.
What were your Saturday?
We played handball all day.
I had to go to a play with my uncle,
the youngest.
You worked for a sports betting place to
later on as I got older,
but when I got out of high school,
I was such a loser.
Then I went to 118th street.
The guy's name was Chad,
Jose Torres and the son.
I went through them like a man.
They were around the block to this guy
named Raleigh and Miguel and they ran a
complete different operation from the
cooperation.
Raleigh still around.
If I had any balls left,
I go put a bullet and Riley's had
because Raleigh was tight with my
mother.
My mother helped get Raleigh started on
118th street.
When my mother died,
he got tight with my stepfather.
When my stepfather died,
he took that money and gave it to my
stepfather.
Sister.
That money belonged to me.
So today I'm still pissed off
at Raleigh because when I was a kid,
I just want to Raleigh every fucking
day.
He gave me 50 bucks.
Every time I went over there,
those guys lived their life.
I'm a Karma based life,
so whenever they see Joe Rogan come in,
feel man,
you know how many things I did with your
father to come in as $100.
Go Get your Dick sucked.
My mother would drive me crazy.
Like how much money did you get to?
200.
Could give me $100 of that because I
used to buy knives and fucking stars to
throw at people,
but that's there with.
They're very generous Joe Rowe,
you know,
you can't do that when you come over to
my house with your daughters.
I can't.
First thing is they do is put a 50 and
everybody's here.
So now the girls know whenever they
would come over uncle Joey's,
they get a 50.
So even after you're not around,
they'll come over when they're 14 and
they going to go to Hollywood.
They'll come over by uncle joe,
Uncle Joey.
When you girls,
you girls got money is 50.
So I had people giving me money because
it's a car.
I'm a base business.
The more I,
my mother would hit the number for
$10,000 to give away.
Really?
Yeah.
Because that's the generosity part of
it.
It's part of the community.
It's part of the.
That's the thing.
You were talking about the communal
communal and I think that was even more
pronounced with the Cubans because of
the history of Bollito and the cultural
significance of belief going back to
Cuba.
That's something they brought with them
to the United States and that was just,
you know,
like I said,
it wasn't seen as a,
as a criminal thing.
It wasn't seen as a violent criminal
thing.
Now what happens with Jose Miguel battle
is at a certain point in 1985,
he moves from union city to Miami and he
moves the hierarchy of the organization
to Miami,
but the money is still being made in New
York City.
The organization is as strong as ever in
the money's being made in the five
boroughs of New York and it's being
shipped down to Miami where this guy now
lives like a,
a gentleman farmer on an estate.
He surrounds himself with mamay trees,
a mamay.
Is it fruit from Cuba that he associates
that?
The Shaker here?
He goes,
sure.
Oh yeah.
They did wonderful fruit.
Beautiful.
The great military.
So he associated with his childhood.
So the first thing he does is he
surrounds his estate down in Miami with
this fruit from his childhood and he
lives down there now far removed from
New York.
Meanwhile,
back in New York,
a war breaks out between the Italians
and the Cubans over this thing called
the two block rule.
When the Cubans and the Italians form
their alliance,
they established a rule that you
couldn't,
nobody could open up a believer to spot
closer than two blocks to a preexisting
bullied to spot somebody violated that
rule.
I don't even know,
after investigating and who,
who violated that rule.
But that rule got violated and it turned
into a nasty,
a war.
And arson war,
they started firebombing each other
spots and a lot of innocent people got
killed.
Man incinerated,
a four year old girl got killed.
Uh,
it became horrific.
Lasted for about eight or nine months.
There was something like 70 murders may
be 25 fire bombings at different spots.
It got so ugly,
it brought down the heat of the feds.
Nobody could ignore this corporation
thing anymore.
So it brought a lot of unwanted
attention to.
They know who initially started it off.
Who violated.
Yeah,
yeah.
He became a snitch and told the whole
story.
The guy who violated it.
Oh nothing.
I violated it.
But the guy who became the number one
arsonist set up the whole campaign of
arson.
He became a snitch and told the whole
thing,
chapter and verse.
So it's basically just one cocky person
just decided,
fuck this to blow.
He was probably authorized by his bosses
to do it.
Yeah.
Go over and burn that spot.
We'll show them.
And then that happened and then the
response was,
well,
we'll show them.
Go burn his spot.
But burning the spot came out of someone
violating the original deal.
Yeah,
two blocks away.
That was the reason.
The first burning half.
Do they know who the guy was?
That started the first day to sit down.
They had a sit down about it.
Here's how failed.
It was.
The Italians and the Cubans had a major
sit down about it to discuss it,
to try to resolve it,
to keep it from exploding into war.
At that sit down,
they didn't resolve anything and after
they came out of the restaurant where
the sit down took place,
a drive by shooting occurred and one of
the Cubans got shot at the restaurant
coming out of the sit down and then the
war was on.
Man.
It was on like battle said,
we're at war with the Italians.
That's what he said with his people and
battle was ready for it.
Man.
He was good to go.
I mean he,
he was ready for that war.
He seemed to want it.
He seemed to cherish the idea that they
were going to go to war with the
Italians and so they were ordering all
these horrific and you know how they did
the arsons they'd get these Mama Luke's
to fill up a,
a pail with gasoline.
Not,
not even a can,
not even a closed Canon Open Pale and
you know,
they could spill and they took that pail
of gas and they'd walk into a Bodega,
bullied the spot and they dump it on the
floor and light it on fire.
And whoever happened to be in there too
bad for them.
And people would die a horrible death
that got incinerated.
I have some pictures in the book that
are almost too horrific.
I had others that were so bad.
I didn't want to use them in the book.
Really?
You put something in that book that
really blew my mind.
You said that in 1975 or 76 in the
Hudson county where I'm from,
there was 40 car bombings.
Oh Man.
Forty car.
Well,
I remember one bombings,
not all car bombing in Hudson county
from seventh street.
The 88th street there.
Will you have bail?
Oh,
bulking up.
There was 41 car bombings.
There was a time in the seventies in the
US were bombings.
Homemade bombs were like the preferred a
weapon of organized.
There were.
There was a.
There was a bombing war in Cleveland
over this Irish gangster in the
seventies.
It was.
It was pretty common to.
They made a bomb with the males.
The guy who had gotten the Sicilians
were good.
They did make a movie about Danny Green.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
What was that movie called?
Kill the kill the Irishmen.
And now that we're doing it again while
they're doing the Irishman different
movie.
Yeah.
It's fascinating stuff,
man.
Now,
did anything surprise you when you were,
you were putting me in.
Obviously you're well versed in
organized crime and well versed and
these kinds of things.
I think,
uh,
the dominant feeling people will have
when they're reading this book is the
dominant feeling I had when I was
researching,
which was why don't I know this shit.
I mean,
this is really,
this is not only a great story really
interesting,
but it's really important history,
all this political connection to
anti-castro movement and the role that
the US government might have played in
it.
And the idea that this criminal
conspiracy organization was allowed to
go on for 40 years because certain
elements in theU ,
s government didn't want to go after
them because they were afraid it would
open the lid on the Cuban relations with
the,
the anti-castro relations with the CIA,
the politics of it.
That's,
that's,
that's not only interesting history.
It's important history to understand a
certain social political relationship
between the US and Cuba,
the Bay of Pigs,
the residue of the revolution that way,
the way that shaped the cold war shaped
us politics over a period of about 50
years.
So I was like,
why don't I know this?
This is amazing.
This is like almost like a hidden
history.
I mean I knew what got reported in the
newspapers,
but you know,
you lift up the rug and you,
you look underneath the rug and you
start to get into the details of it.
It just makes me so aware that what
we're receiving as information on a
daily basis from the meat,
mainstream media and everything is a
version of what's happening.
There's a whole other version of what's
happening that we don't see and you
usually only find out about it 30 years
later,
30 years after the fact,
and that's a good thing to know.
Yeah.
I mean,
it sounds to me like this is A.
I've,
I haven't heard a peep about this.
When you brought this up to me,
joey and I was like,
what?
The Cuban organized crime,
the corporation.
What?
What is this like?
This is not discussed.
It's just not.
Well,
hopefully this will change.
I grew up in it and I never talked about
it because like I said,
I have a hundred stores we go for around
a buzzfeed.
Right,
right,
right.
There's a lot of shit.
I was saying that I don't say it because
number one,
you're not going to believe me,
and number two,
it's not my position.
I was raised as nothing me to say.
Do you remember that?
Yes,
but I saw that as a child and then what
made it worse for me,
it was moving to North Bergen.
Once I moved north Bergen,
I saw what they were doing in union city
in a bigger way,
which is all political.
I saw things that are make it tone drop.
That's why I don't give a fuck about
politics and the one when I see people
talking about politics,
I want to go up to them and go,
if you knew what you were talking about,
you wouldn't say a word because you have
no idea what real politics means.
How it works if it works like that and a
micro system I can't imagine.
And a real.
So I don't want to pay attention to
join.
Let me ask you a question because I,
I joined and I connected when I had more
or less written this already.
Um,
if I had come to you way back at the
beginning of this,
out of the blue,
all of a sudden this Guy Tj English,
I don't know you because you knew the
westies.
So you knew who I was.
He knew I was legit.
If I had contacted you and said,
will you talk to me about this history?
Would you have done it with everything?
It would take us a week to debrief me.
So you would have been ready in will.
I would have told you.
Now you see what's interesting,
that thing I would have known because
somebody has.
Yeah.
Here,
this fucking story.
He opened up the door for me.
I have a responsibility now that I have
another story that,
to this.
Yes he does.
I have the nuts and bolts of how this
works.
Have you thought about in addition to
this?
I think there's going to be a number of
spin off books from this.
This is really a book that comes from.
This is going to tell their personal
story shot.
I will end up dead.
Really.
Not because of the.
Because of what I'm exposed to.
We know who did it in.
In a,
in a.
You know,
I grew up when I was growing up,
the power in that Hudson county was the
waterfront Digi.
That picture in New York City that
people see.
Thousands of people died for that
waterfront.
That waterfront was controlled by
wheelock and.
But everybody wanted a piece of it and
North Bergen,
one of the pieces of it.
So my eighth grade teacher was the
weehawken man.
You ever have a teacher?
That was a man.
Why would a teacher be a mayor of a
town?
What?
Why,
why?
Who's ever had a teacher tweet that was
the mayor of a town at the same time I
did.
And guess what?
At the end of my eighth grade,
did atf come in and pull them out of
that real?
He did 11 years.
Okay.
I was doing,
he was selling the waterfront.
He all that,
that they knew that there's a particular
family that I will not mentioned because
I won't even make it to the four.
Oh,
five.
And they were buying that property up
change 60?
No,
no,
it will buying that property up in the
sixties.
They were posing as politicians.
They chop up $30 million a month now
between four and then it.
No,
no,
no.
This is from all of the property they
own in Hudson county.
They bought everything.
Jersey City hoboken.
And they make their profit selling it?
No,
no.
They made their profit renting it or
renting it.
So the four of them before brothers,
Chubb $30 million.
They go their own ways every month.
They chopper 30 million.
So I started from North Bergen.
When I tell you stories about columbine
bows,
Zana,
he was a cop.
He was a cop to that I got invited into.
He opened up his home to me.
Then his son died,
the one that was my age,
so I became a pseudo sun.
So here I am running with the Cubans
during the week.
They're talking about numbers and drugs
and everything,
and I'm growing up in a cop's house.
That's also the driver for the mayor and
he would do whatever,
like I still owe him handcuffed dudes
and throw Beaton's on them and they call
them the tour.
They call them combine the torch Mazano,
because his job was to burn your
building down.
The last one he burned down.
Kids were like,
Mr. Mr that smoke,
and he's like,
here's $10.
Who can ice cream?
I'll call the fire department.
He never called him.
He faked a heart attack.
So you don't have to talk to reporters.
First thing you do is you fake a heart
attack because you don't have to talk to
reporters.
That gives you two days to get your
story straight with the attorney that
you have no idea what I know now.
Now the reason I asked,
showing the question about whether he
would have been willing to talk is a lot
of people reached out to me early in
this book process.
The,
uh,
the,
the movie rights were options before I
even wrote the book based on the book
proposal.
And I got a lot of media attention and I
started getting emails from nieces and
nephews have sons and daughters of key
characters in the story,
and these were people like joey who had
kept us personal family history,
bottle cap,
hadn't talked to anybody about it,
and now they saw I was doing this book
and they and they needed to get it off
their chest.
They needed to talk about it.
I would go.
I met these two,
these two girls who were daughters of
one of the guys who became a snitch,
testified against the corporation.
The family went into the witness
protection program.
These girls had never talked to anybody.
When I met,
went to meet with them in a bar.
They weren't even sure they were going
to talk to me.
We were just meeting to talk about
whether they were going to talk to me.
I got to meet them.
They talk nonstop for three hours and
once they thought they could trust me,
they just,
they couldn't stop talking about it.
They had all the stuff they needed to
get off their chest.
Wow.
Raised.
Not to say God's God's the first raid.
I saw my mother,
I was five.
They sat me on the couch and read.
My mother had already thrown the coke
off about the until the lady downstairs,
the landlord had already called her and
said,
the cops are on the way out the door.
We lived on the west side,
terrorists facing a new New Jersey,
and the lady,
she would pay her rent and tell a hold
this bag.
My mother through it,
they came up,
sat is down.
They asked the subway,
went to Ada Street,
88th street.
We never got raided.
When I moved to North Bergen,
I would get raided before I got ready to
the phone would ring and become.
I know that your mom had cleaned the
house.
I'd wake my mom up to clean the house
and come over here.
I don't want you to see what's going to
happen.
Cops would come and arrest my mother.
I would walk the columbines obs with my
basketball right past the cops and it
was that easy.
It was that easy.
Wow.
Do you wish you ran into joey before you
started writing this?
It would've been a different book.
He wanted.
Why I enjoyed this book so much is
because no matter how much history this
motherfucker dropped on you,
he let you know Jose Battle was.
He kept you.
Remind them who's Jose Battle was.
That's big for an author.
He never got away from Jose battle and
when you read the book,
no matter what type of person you are,
you kind of get mad at Jose battle,
but there's something about Jose battery
life cause you.
You want that guy in your corner.
If you knew Jose battle and you knew
that he got in the truck and say,
I'm going out there for my men,
that's the guy I want with me all the
time.
What am I going to hang out with this
fucking idiot?
He gets scattered.
If an ambulance goes by,
this guy actually went out and saved
that guys.
So he had that Cuban loyalty that Anti
Castro Cubans.
Shit.
That's big.
So growing up there was so many things I
wasn't allowed to.
I wasn't even allowed to talk about.
Now,
here's how ruthless this guy.
Well,
let me,
let,
let you answer the question though.
Do you wish that you would run into joe?
Ah,
yes I do,
but the thing that fears me,
there was so much research to do in this
book.
If I would have met Joey,
I would have gone down a rabbit hole
with joey stories and that might've
taken me off this specific research I
was doing,
so I almost joey joey's thing is like a
separate thing.
It's almost like a a sequel to or a sub
or a son.
The son of the corporation,
sort of a spinoff of it and there's a
lot of people probably who have their
version of it like joey does that they
could tell,
so yeah.
But let me say about battle because Joey
St,
very interesting thing.
How charismatic he was and how you
partly liked him and admired him,
which was was the,
is the case of any good leader,
right?
That's what you want from a leader.
But here's how ruthless this guy was.
He had a guy in his organization or
Nesto Torres,
Ernesto,
who he met in Spain.
Battle was on the run in Madrid for a
brief period of time when he'd been
indicted on gambling charges and there
were a bunch of Cubans living over there
and they all hung out together and he.
He discovered this 19 year old kid named
Ernesto Torres,
who was sort of an orphan and one day he
tells the kid he's going to mentor the
kid.
One day,
tells the kid,
I've got a guy coming this afternoon to
the apartment.
I want you to watch.
He owes me $10,000.
I'm going to scare the shit out of this
guy.
I want you to see what you do,
how you treat somebody who owes you
money,
show them that they can't play around
with you.
So he's waiting for the guy to come over
battle and he's sitting in his apartment
and here's a pop pop from out in the
street.
He goes down,
he goes out.
Earnest Eco.
Nineteen year old is there with a gun in
his hand.
He's shot the guy in the backseat of the
cab arriving to meet with battling,
killing him.
And he says,
uh,
Padrino Godfather.
He says,
you'll never have a problem with this
guy again.
I took care of it and battles looking at
it going,
Ugh,
you just cost me $10,000.
I didn't want the guy dead.
Uh,
but then again,
he looks at her and he thinks I can use.
I can use this guy,
I can use this guy.
So earnest ego becomes what he calls his
protocol son.
And he grooms this guy to maybe be the
next Godfather.
When they come back to New Jersey,
they come back to union city.
He,
he sends this Guy Ernest,
he go out there and no one else in the
corporation can understand battles.
Affection for this guy they think are in
a tequilas thug.
He's a killer.
He's a street dog.
Yeah,
the organization can use guys like that,
but you don't put him in positions of
authority.
Battle scene have a soft spot for this
guy.
He makes earnest tico a banker.
He makes the other bankers bank roll,
uh,
put up $10,000 each so that earnest can
be a banker.
They don't like it.
Most of them don't like it,
but they go along with a couple of them.
Don't go along with it.
Ernest ego doesn't have the brains to be
a banker.
He fails miserably as a banker.
He's humiliated by that.
And so what he does,
he starts kidnapping bankers from the
organization and holding them for money,
very self destructive thing to do.
He turns against the organization.
He goes rogue.
One of them is shoots a banker.
He kidnaps and shoots happens to be
paddles,
brother-in-law.
The bankers come to Jose Miguel battle.
They say,
you,
you created this,
this fucking monster.
You brought this kid in.
You created them.
You got to take care of it.
That'll be in the man.
He is.
Realizes that that's true.
It's his responsibility.
He hires a few assassins to try to take
her in St.
Cloud.
They bomb his car in union city.
They tried to kill him.
They can't get the job done.
Battle decides he's got to do the thing
himself.
By this time,
Ernest Tico has fled to Miami.
He's hiding out with his girlfriend in
OPA.
Locka battle gets together,
his brother,
one of his brothers and another
assassin,
Chino Akuna and a day go down to.
They go down to Miami and in the middle
of the afternoon they burst in this guy,
they find out where he as a person,
his apartment,
they engage in a wild shootout with her
and it's Tico and they shoot him in the
closet of his bedroom at battle,
goes in,
grabs him by the hair and shoots him
right ripe.
It puts a bullet right between his eyes.
Now that's a boss.
I mean,
aside from the horrible nature of the
act,
that's a leader.
That's a guy who
takes matters into his own hands.
He wants something done.
He goes and does it himself and uses
that as an example for the organization.
He comes back to the bosses,
the bankers in New York.
He says,
you're not going to have a problem with
with ernest eco anymore.
He says,
you know what?
He died like a lion.
He fought to the death.
He empty.
He fought until he'd empty his gun and
shot him in the closet.
So he's telling all the other backers,
I still admire the kid.
He fought like a lion,
but I took care of it.
It's done.
And you know the other,
the other belief the bankers were in.
We're in awe of this guy because he had
a certain ability to do that,
that they didn't have this in the book.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
There's pictures of it in the blue.
What was the logic to take this thug and
tournament to a banker in the first
place?
He had a soft spot for him.
Battle was a sentimentalist.
He took in stray dogs.
He drive around this.
He'd drive around and he'd see a dog on
the street and he'd open the door and
he'd say,
come if the dog come.
He took the dog in and in his home in
Miami as a state in Miami.
He had like 25 stray dogs.
Wow.
And uh,
they said Ernest Tico is like a stray
dog.
He had a soft spot for the kid before I
piss real quick.
Don't.
Cube with a dog is a big symbol.
My toys was real big circle care.
When Michael Vick got convicted,
there was a lot of jails.
He couldn't be center because they had
an adequate population and they don't
play when it comes to dog because the
devotion is to St Laszlo Way.
St Lazarus who got these,
the ones with the crutches that got his
licks and,
and then his by there was a lot like you
bro,
when people would say that whether you
bring art and Joel is on the real
because I love these motherfuckers and
fuck you.
You got a problem for you.
You know what I'm saying?
That's what he was.
He was very loyal and uh,
until you,
until you turned onto the attorney.
But you know,
they almost canceled the sopranos.
The HBO got really pissed at the
Sopranos.
Episode seven when he drives his
daughter to the school and he kills the
guy personally because hbo felt that
bosses should never do heads.
That was,
he did that over time.
Hbo Film,
Hbo felt they were,
that they were that chase.
Fuck this Ross Greenberg.
They will chase and said,
we don't think in real life a boss maybe
went and he picked up the guy by his
neck when he drove a whatever,
willow,
the college that the hbo threatened the
Sopranos,
not the add that episode to cut that,
to make somebody else killed a guy that
wasn't the only guy.
Was that because they wanted Tony
Soprano.
They still wanted them to be some sort
of a hero.
They didn't understand that he wanted to
keep your hands clean.
Then the ridiculous because that was one
of the more appealing things about that
show that show he was a murderer.
But you still like no,
at the end that he killed Pilou to uh,
he tried to cut his leg off me.
Tell you a little on fire
and tell you that.
Let Me Go pee real quick.
The police story,
political killed battles brother.
His youngest brother in a dispute shot
him in a,
in a bar in Washington heights.
Very public murder.
I mean as an insult to the battle
family.
So now Jose Miguel battle is fucking
livid.
And at the funeral in union city,
he gathers his men together and he says,
you know,
I want this guys,
I want this guys head on the wall.
I want,
I want to be able to mount this guy's
head on my wall.
And uh,
he,
he puts out a hit on this guy for
$100,000 and this is in the seventies.
So you know,
that's probably a million.
It's probably a million dollars.
A earnest equals the one that takes on
ernest take on another assassin are the
ones that take on that contract and they
go out trying to get pilou.
I mentioned before,
there's something like nine attempts or
12 attempts on Palooz life.
They had a shoot out in central park
with machine guns in the middle of the
afternoon.
Holy Shit,
guys with machine guns shooting with
mothers with baby carriages and stuff.
Palooza got shot up so bad.
He loses his leg.
He winds up having to have a prosthetic
leg.
They still go after Pilou.
One pilou goes to prison.
They hire a killer to stab him in the
prison yard twice,
two separate times.
And He survived that.
He keeps surviving and he survived.
So many of these assassination attempts,
they,
they think he's not human.
They come to believe that he's got some
sense santeria spirit who's protecting
him.
So when you think someone has this,
I was still,
he was here for this.
When you have someone you think has a
Santeria spirit protecting them,
you have to counter that with a center.
He a spirit of your own.
You have to have what's called the
Bombay,
where you were,
you were.
You create a,
a kind of Voodoo energy to kill this
guy.
So they.
So they continue to go after poodle.
Finally battle as he did with Ernest
[inaudible] says,
I'm going to take matters into my own
hands.
I'm going to.
I'm going to be there on this one.
They find out where Pilou is in the
Bronx and they go on one night and they
trap him.
They see cars come from all sides.
They trap him.
He gets out of his car,
they shoot him in the street,
they shoot them full of 11 bullets.
He falls in the street,
a bleeding loaded with gunshots.
The last thing he sees is Jose Miguel
battle standing over him,
laughing at him,
and then he goes unconscious in the
street.
They think,
great,
he's dead.
They're almost ready to celebrate.
The following morning they find out now
polluted was rushed to the hospital.
He's not dead.
He's recovering now.
They're beside themselves.
What corneal.
They've tried everything.
Uh,
they say,
you know what?
We're not going to give up.
They hire an assassin.
Dress him up as a male nurse.
He goes into the hospital,
shoots Pilou in his,
in his hospital bed right between the
eyes and it got to.
They got the job done.
He was talking when you were gone,
about how if you felt like a guy had a
Santa Ria spirit protecting them,
you had to have your own Santa Maria to
come back to combat it.
Santa Ria became a scam after.
Well,
like I was raised in Santa Maria from
the age of five.
I had little disturbances when my dad
died.
I was weak.
I didn't.
They didn't put me into Santa Ria to be
a witch.
Doctor explained Santa Maria to people
who don't know what,
it's a religion that originated in
Africa,
Nigeria,
and then the slaves brought it over to
Cuba.
They hit it from the plantation owners
through Catholicism,
so that's why there's a lot of cross.
It's kind of a mixture of African
Catholic Catholic religion.
When I was five I was brought up to
148th street and this lady had a collie
dog and I loved the Cali.
I love dogs and I was allergic to them,
so while I was playing with the dog,
she would talk to me and I fell in love
with this woman.
I fell in love with her.
She was like my mother and then as I got
older,
one that they asked me,
do you want this?
Do you want that?
Do you want to get like,
wow.
Which is the first one you get at like
Wildo Goon,
Yoel Romero.
Those are the first things you get and
you put them by your door and they
guarantee you know your safety.
For me it was health.
That big black woman who is my
godmother.
Okay.
And then after that,
when I was six,
they finally said they were going to
initiate me and my mother because my
spirit took my father.
Wow.
So they wanted my godmother.
They wanted me and my mother to be twins
in the Santa Maria.
So I made st 148th street and Broadway
and.
But for me it wasn't to be a killer or
would it be anything like that?
I can't carry guns.
I can't go in cars with strange people.
I can't do business with three people.
I can't say.
I hope Jamie fucking gets hit by a car.
I'm not allowed to say all those things.
I don't use it the way in the late 17
you do business with three people
because two of them will sidle up
against you.
And that's the same thing that happened
to me on my kidnapping.
I rob somebody with three people.
I can't stay in everything.
I look at my life now look at my life
when I was a white powder,
my st in my head is controlled.
Like that's why I always wearing a white
t shirt on Mondays.
It's a day of this.
You always wear a white t shirt or
Monday.
Look at my shoes.
White on white.
Always when I step out of the shower I
walk on totally on our mat everyday,
everyday,
everyday.
I'm still very Santa Maria in my head.
I wasn't when I was doing the coke
because I knew I wasn't allowed to.
What happened in the in the mid
seventies with St Dharia was I would pay
you to tell me what you wanted to hear.
Listen,
I got a big cargo coming in from
Columbia with 100 kilos.
What will the St say I do?
It's fucking religion.
They don't fucking transport blow,
but these people got enamored with it,
so it was like,
you know a Dj,
you know,
I want to kill Joe Rogan.
Let me put a spouse and you're supposed
to write your name on a thing and then
take a tongue and put it in the cow's
tongue.
Like there was a big story when I was a
kid for dotty.
One of a story that he's in the book.
He's Omega Seven.
I didn't know this growing up.
He went to court one time and his
godmother made a powder and before the
judge went to make a verdict,
she splayed the power and the thing and
the judge fucking couldn't remember what
the fuck he was about to say,
dismissed the case and she became a star
after that.
Every fucking criminal wanting to give
her thousands of dollars.
What was the powder like a thing they
made.
There's a movie they called years ago.
It was a the devil's advocate with a
with Keanu reeves and Pachino and
there's one scene where he has to go
protect the guy.
The guy's a Santa Ria guy.
New York is prosecuting him because he's
killing animals without a license and he
goes,
watch this.
He takes a tongue and he puts the tongue
down.
He blasts the tongue with like a thing
and then he says.
He asked the guy what's the judge's
name?
And the judge gave him his name and he
took the tongue and they roll it with
nails and then they put it away and they
go,
don't worry about tomorrow.
The next day at court,
the judge starts to fucking talk and he
goes and pull up coughing.
Spring.
He can't fucking talk.
Now that person looks like a hero.
These are all subtle coincidence that
these fucking specs for fueled by now.
So now I gotta I got have a big week.
Joe Rogan.
What is the St say you get four pieces
of coconut.
You throw them on the floor and the St
say this is going to be your week.
Let me give you a $20,000.
So now drug dealers started doing it
with Noriega got busted.
He had Santa Maria in his closet.
Fidel was well known for Santa Maria and
his closet dudes.
Well,
they have a.
You have a special moment.
You have an altar.
I made a promise when I lived in that
apartment that have got.
If about the law,
got me a house,
he would have his own room.
Go to my house.
My St isn't my office right behind me.
I'm not an author and I also have a few.
If you get into the Cuban thing,
it will get you.
We'll get it will get you.
It's so cute from reading this book I
have.
I haven't to have an.
You have to have like,
why's my.
He's a little boy.
You do this.
It's a belief system.
Why did you do?
Because you can't really understand a
culture unless you embrace it on some
level.
You understand it and live it.
Unless you continued even after the
book.
Oh yeah.
I've had people talk to me when I've
thrown cards or by you throwing cards
about when people have done my readings.
They have mentioned you in my readings
really that you're around the euro.
A lot of sun all the way to the end.
What does that mean about the lives on
the old wise,
he has 24 different passages.
He goes my passages or Jago?
Nah,
that's the one you don't want around
because they were supposed to push out
and go in my head,
but the time me down,
I wish I chunk.
Chunk.
Go means thunder.
Whenever you see thundery shit,
that's Chango.
Chango is a bad and a woman.
You can't kill mice around him.
They beheaded them because a mouse woke
him up and he woke up and Oh,
it's fucked.
You have no idea.
And is the drum the Conga drum,
which is to thunder.
Summoning the thunder.
Yeah.
So they put a box in my head to calm me
down.
I'm not supposed to carry weapons.
I can't have knives on me.
I can't get into arguments.
My mother in the same dot,
Chung.
She's just a whore.
She's just a tune.
Is the horror of the same.
She gave him a kid.
So yeah,
my Yada res.
If you have problems with your stomach
or you want to have a kid,
you have to pray it or chew you know.
But the women's saints have worse than
the male saints.
You don't fuck around with the women
sayings because they will fuck your
world up tune is probably Mary Magdalen.
Yes.
And My.
I sent a message to my mother.
My Mother didn't do it.
My mother died,
you know,
he says that there's a,
a,
another side to the story and you know,
like I told him the last time we have
this Michael,
my mother had made for years.
They sent me the sacred heart school for
boys.
Yeah,
she sent me that a good education,
but she sent me that because it was a
lot of shit she didn't want me to say at
that time and when I got a Catholic
school I was introduced to it and one of
the things I got introduced in one night
was the end of union city.
The end of that political era where
everything was running smooth came to an
end,
like in 76.
That's when allegations started to come
up because there was two cops that would
shake my mother down.
Very decent people.
They would come in when I came well
dressed,
would have a drink,
talk to my mother in Spanish.
My mother would feed him.
It was a price of doing business,
Joe Rogan.
Now,
here's how I knew joey was legit because
when we first started communicating,
he mentioned the name of one of these
cops and that name is in the book,
uh,
Frank Mona,
a well known cop in union city at the
time,
so I knew right away to your house and
you had $200,000,
only 100,000 dollars and make it to the
police station.
So my step father Juan wanted to kill
him.
He confiscated ones lecture to 25.
That was like,
for,
you know,
like when Tony Montana picks up Michelle
five and he goes,
what is God lack,
let me tell you.
So you could put a porsche,
the best portion of the world and the
1975 cadillac makes to a Cuban and he's
going to take the cadillac because
that's,
that's a scheme that's radical.
That's what it is to be fucking.
When Mona took that Cadillac from one,
he didn't shut up about that for 10
years.
He wants to shoot that fucking cop.
But that cop was a clean cut.
There was a dirty cop and he always
busted my mother's balls,
but he wouldn't come in for the
shakedowns.
It was two other guys thought about 76.
This guy started coming out and that
kind of looked like a,
like Jim Morrison,
Cuban,
good looking dude when another white
partner and they would come in and they
would yell at my mother and my mom had a
bar,
the pool table on the back and then she
had a main office.
If she had to take a number or somebody
might have to play a number.
She rented an apartment.
She owned the building,
so she rented the apartment upstairs
that had a line to the back so you
couldn't follow them saying 10 so you
could choose to the back office.
I was in that back office one day and I
heard yelling and I came outside and
this cop was pressuring my mother
saying,
fuck you.
We know what the fuck you're doing.
We want our money.
Now.
At that time,
union city ran from seven to 48th street
and there was a bunch of bars.
Was a cafe.
The cafe of artists at Brean d,
these are all well known Cuban book,
your spot and this guy started torturing
Cubans and the Cubans were like,
what the fuck is going on?
We pay and all of a sudden this guy,
but will piss the Cubans off the most
was that this guy was cute.
His name was nicky Gerardo,
and he was,
you know what happened and this kept on
and one day I'm in.
I used to go to Mckinley school and I
would walk up to my mother's bar and one
day I walked up there and every one of
those Cuban owners were in there
drinking fucking yelling and that Castro
Shit.
There was one way before the subprime
was his name was treating.
That means sad pussy.
He owned the club on 35th street.
Now in union city,
you also have to remember there's a bar
called the bottom of the barrel and if
you read any mafia books,
the bottom of the barrels and every
mafia book,
it sounds.
It's where Henry Hill hung out.
Dominic,
Montego Leo and Nino Gaji.
It's right there.
I'm bergenline avenue.
So all this was going on and you didn't
sit.
So he's the real fucking deal.
Okay.
It's real now.
Fucking.
Yeah.
Now before we get off Santa Maria.
Uh,
yeah.
I told you the story about Ernest tico
right after an stk who got murdered and
they searched his apartment.
They found a bunch of tapes.
He had been taping phone conversations
with all the people around him and he
taped some conversations with his mother
packing Kua.
Ernest Eagle knew he was hunt a hunted
man.
He,
they had been attempts.
He was hiding out in a phone
conversation with his mother like three
days before they got him.
He's talking with his mother and she
says,
I know.
I'm worried.
I know they're trying to get you.
I knew I'm going to do a bay to try to
protect you.
And he says,
yeah,
I need it.
You know,
he says,
I'm caught in the middle of a war of the
saints.
And she says,
I need some new names for my mba.
And he names the people who have been
been a,
a ceremony,
uh,
you know,
a ceremonial summoning of the spirits
for one purpose or another,
and she was above allow a priestess.
Um,
so he gives her the very people who are
after him,
Jose Miguel battle,
he says a Chino or Konya,
he names all the people who are trying
to kill him.
So there's mother can use those names in
her ceremony.
So when the cops find this,
obviously the Bombay didn't work because
they killed that,
got to ernest tico and killed them.
But on the other hand,
when the cops found this tape,
it was like Ernestine covas speaking
from the dead and fingering his,
the people who killed him and they were
able to use that as evidence.
They knew exactly who killed him because
of that tape conversation with
Blah,
blah,
blah.
So how the fuck do I fit in the Santa
Maria?
What do you on a couple of years ago I
had to read some guy told me that you
have a couple of strong above a lot of
people in your life and that's
definitely you.
You're older and wiser guy.
You're not violent or very controlled.
You're a lot more controlled than I am,
which is more of A.
I lean towards the jungle phase.
My,
my main thing is a Jago now yoga,
when I was younger by the law,
he's the one that took a sword and wipe
it on his chest with red and they asked
them why,
uh,
did he liked to kill him?
He said,
because blood makes change.
Something stupid.
He really has,
but I don't practice that.
I don't.
My brother was very calm,
but one,
one guy goes,
Caesar,
he's a bad ass.
Motherfucker hit mentioned,
didn't mention your name,
didn't need that.
Don't need to mention that.
Once they tell me,
I already know what they're talking
about,
about.
So I still go get readings.
Like when I go to Miami,
next time I go to my godmother.
See,
this is the reason.
One thing I might ask,
I still
follow it.
This is the reason I still follow.
You were asking me why,
why I would still follow it.
It's because once you get to an
understanding of the idea that there are
certain spirits within you and the
Orishas represent different spirits,
once you understand that that's not
something you throw away.
Even if you don't follow the religion
anymore,
you still,
you still have belief in that.
He's still believe in that.
So my Orisha is Elegua.
Elegua is the saint e's.
A trickster.
Elegua is a trickster,
plays little tricks and also the saint
of passages.
So people put elegua above their door
because you're passing from one room
into another room and so you identify
that spirit
and that becomes part of your identity.
You can whistle in the house.
Why?
Why you can't whistle in the house?
Yeah,
I don't listen.
You can go in the house because he'll
leave.
So you can't fuck them whistling.
Can't whistle.
No.
Wow.
When I was a kid,
I'd sit at the table and do.
Yeah,
you can't wait.
So my mom was go touch that fucking
table is gonna wake your fucking head
because God lives on the table now.
Joe.
I grew up in it.
They made st to me like the one when I
made St Louis in November and they ended
up in the Bronx River,
so they had to break the ice and they
were dark skinned Cubans and I'll never
forget that.
They rip your clothes off and then they
take whatever you're saying.
They hit you with the number of water,
so if you're st is five,
you get hit with five things with water
and they dry you out,
you're freezing and when I saw them
ripping my mother's clothes on,
I was about five.
I'm like,
fuck you.
Black motherfuckers started running down
Bronx Boulevard.
They had to chase me and bring me back.
I didn't want to do it.
It's an all night ceremony night on a
Friday.
It was crazy all night.
Twelve hours long sleep and then Sunday
is when they read your future to you and
then for a week you just live in a
corner.
White.
They paint your head,
you're bald.
I had to go back to school on Monday,
bald with a hat.
They said he's not allowed in here with
a hat.
My mother gave the principals small
nickel and I was allowed to wear the hat
from nine to three,
but then at 3:00 I had to go home and
change into white clothes for a year,
not allowing for a year.
I had to dress in white now year,
so for my calls I would just have to
wear white socks and white tee shirts
because I was a kid.
I can't keep wearing fucking white every
damn.
I'm ripping shit right so that your hair
has to grow back.
So when I walk into,
I know there's a ton of Santa Maria and
La Really,
I don't deal with it at all because it's
all the same thing.
Like everything else in their life.
It's a bunch of white people didn't grow
up in it and there's a hot black guy and
they want to really just suck his dick
and he's talking about spirits.
Saw a video today.
I saw a video.
I'm like,
shame on them.
It's all confused.
It's like those white chicks that
sucked.
That Hindu Dick,
when they go to hot yoga,
that guy that's got a bit grumpy is a
pig.
You've got is a bunch of white chicks or
hummus flavor in there from something
that he gets to me inside you.
You suck that fucking.
That smells like hummus chips,
you know,
and that's what it is in La.
Like I've been invited to two parties.
First Time I went,
you know who's in there?
Who fucking the dude from that played in
the Yummy forest?
Forest,
Whitaker Santa Real.
Is He really the chick that won Miss
America for eating pussy from behind the
scenes in the Santa Maria.
Maria.
Oh Vanessa,
my Santa Ria.
I grew up in a Cuban Santa Ria.
You shut your fucking mouth because it's
not cute.
Is it Mexican influence?
This is why they're just like,
oh my God,
look at that.
Look at forest.
It's very watered down.
And look at the guy from forest whitaker
dressed up like fucking monks do pop a
plate that I came up under the very
strict.
Shut your mouth.
Nobody needs to know you fucking
business to fill a role.
It was his step and this is what it is
here.
It's more of a of a,
you know,
like whenever at the guy that I,
the guy that gives me the reeds is
tremendous.
I'm going to tell you this man to man.
Tremendous.
Really tremendous.
I even took Duncan tool.
Tremendous.
You took Duncan,
does she?
We had him on the podcast and
everything.
The problem with him is I don't like his
people around him.
He has too many people that don't know.
When I joined this I knew what I was
getting myself into.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I knew,
I knew I liked it.
I had nothing to do with my mother.
I was to do with my godmother and I.
and it was my relationship with her.
In fact,
my mother couldn't even say shit to me
in front of my godmother when,
when an 85 I,
I might,
when I moved in with the vendors,
I couldn't bring my Santa Ria shit with
them.
They're fucking aliens.
So I left it with this gay guy named
Martin.
The fact my thing money go.
You sold coke at night.
He was,
uh,
he was,
a seamstress in the daytime for a big
New York play,
but when I was a kid,
he would go to cbgbs every night and so
coke use all these fags walking around
and Felicia give thanks to Martin.
He was getting his teeth knocked out and
black eyes back in the seventies because
he was gay.
But I liked one.
I ended up my,
I left my St Martin and then years later
they ended up Robin Martin,
my cocaine fucking hell.
So my godmother asked me in 1,985,
whereas you're saying,
so I go there at Martin's house.
She goes,
you know,
you're not supposed to have.
You're saying to the gay man's house.
I'll go get him.
Listen to me.
I never saw my godmother going have 95.
I did A.
I talked to Duncan about Santa Maria and
some company approached me from London
and I did the Santa Ria podcasts and I
got an email on twitter.
We know who has you,
saints.
They're in Miami.
Thirty four years later I flew to Miami.
I got my son to get him.
I flew together,
shifting back,
you know how my godmother got him to
Miami out on a bus.
Whoa.
So six cases on a bus with all your
future and your stuff.
I got my notebook.
If you look at my notebook,
I bring my notebook next time.
And you reading your go.
Joe Knew Shit.
These motherfuckers really?
Oh yeah.
So you,
you,
you believe there's something to it.
I till the age of 11,
I thought there were a bunch of Hocus
pocus motherfuckers,
but there was a lady on 20,
sixth and central and I grew up with her
kids.
Her husband was that big book in on an
Eighteenth Street and once a month she
passed the spirit and people would go
there.
10 people who were invited and I could
tell this cop was eating away at my
mother.
First of all,
my mother didn't lay down for nobody.
My mother was going to shoot that
motherfucker herself.
She'd,
if she was that type of Cuban woman.
She didn't like being spoken to that way
I could see it in their face.
It was eating him alive and one night we
went over to this way or these party.
The first time I saw the lady drink a
bottle of fire water,
you know,
that hundred and 40 proof Agua dam
thing.
So I thought,
this is bullshit.
This is bullshit.
This is she MCS that bottle out in the
daytime.
So at night I would watch her bottles
and they had the label like they were
sealed because I had my mother had a bar
so I knew if they were sealed in a pro,
just women would pass the spirit and
then tell you what to do and what not to
do.
On this particular night,
she went up to my mother.
She goes,
I know what's bothering you.
And she took a white dish,
took a white dish.
That was just the way she took a candle
and she turned it over and she went like
this,
this circular motion on the camera.
I was 10 or 11 Joe Rogan at that time
that I believe I don't believe in Dick.
I didn't believe in Dick.
I didn't believe in Jesus.
I don't give a fuck.
It's a story they tell you.
She flipped over the dish and it was a
circle with a guy that looked like a
beer and she goes,
this was bothering you.
And my mother goes,
yeah.
She goes,
and she broke the dishes.
seven days,
they will never bother you again.
Four days later,
go look it up.
Nikki Gerardo was his name.
They shot them a thousand fucking times
at a place called Rapido taxi.
It was a front.
There was a taxi thing that was a front
for a cocaine.
They deliver cocaine.
Ropey don't means quick.
They never had a customer that caps.
He wants to make a collection.
They were waiting for the one you told
me about you,
Geraldo.
They said they got the witness wasn't no
witness was the union city cops who
shot.
Wow.
Because he went by.
It's like if and you have partners and
also that come around and start
collecting from jail.
That's how corrupt the system.
And in the papers they said he died to
hear all that.
He was shot by a street criminal and he
was given her heroes.
Perio.
No.
And Joey says he was shot by other.
No,
they know.
They always knew the city.
Was that dirty?
Did you hear this when you were doing
your research?
No,
I didn't.
When I told him that he told me and I
did some research on it,
found out that the guy,
I read the public account of
what happened and it was quite different
than what,
how joey describes it.
That was the cops and Charlotte because
he's taken.
And that's what I was saying before
about the what the story we see on the
surface and then the real story
underneath.
See,
I know all those stores don't like the
after that,
the political system.
And in his book he has a section where
you actually see battle go to the police
station and to make payoffs like that's
how easy it was.
You know,
battle got arrested in north Bergen in
my hometown.
So I called one of my friends.
I go do some research on it.
They said they never even put the cops
on him.
He owned the town.
He owned the town,
the mayor and the police chief.
And if you all you need to say they both
went to prison eventually for taking
money from the gambling.
From.
Yeah.
No Mayor Jamie,
when you got a minute.
No Man has ever left Hudson county.
If it's not through prison,
the whole,
the male,
the fact Guinea,
he died because it was 800 pounds.
Every other man ends up in jail.
My.
The fact that Mary Union city is up for
corruption charges as we speak.
And this is what,
30 years later I read that.
I read that recently.
It's never stopped Joe Rogan.
It's never ever stopped.
That's why when people tell me stories,
I wipe my ass.
And also this is when you say organized
crime is diminished while we're talking
about organized crime,
right?
It's still there.
It's deeply rooted in the system in
certain jurisdictions and it's not going
to change.
It's just crazy to me that you got so
deeply entrenched reading the story that
you started getting into Santa Maria.
I was actually until I was married to a
Brazilian for 10 years.
So they have a center.
It's called my coma.
And what's different about their.
It's almost exactly the same and they
have all the same saints.
It's the same thing.
Same thing because the slave trade came
through Brazil,
Africa,
Catholicism mixing.
They,
they just.
The music is different with the Cubans.
It's a Roomba.
All this wonderful room by music that
you hear.
There's a whole bunch of great music
that grows up around it.
So you were married to a Brazilian
woman.
You get divorced to keep the religion
because that would happen.
Uh,
yeah.
I,
I was.
I can't go to places like Cuba and
Brazil because I get so influenced and
overwhelmed by it.
It changes the direction my life really.
I went to Brazil for the first full day.
I was in Brazil.
I fell in love with the woman that I
married and lived with for the next 10
years.
Wow.
When I go to Cuba,
it's dangerous to me because I'm so
seduced by it.
I'm so intoxicated by Havana.
By Cuban culture.
What is it?
Well,
first of all,
it's the most sensual place you have.
Van is the most sensual place I've ever
been.
Everyone flirts.
The women flirt.
Doesn't matter if they're married or not
married.
They flirt with you.
I suppose guys flirt to everyone flirts.
There's like sexual energy everywhere.
The Sky in the and the climate is just
kind of sold tree in and sensual.
The music is.
Makes your body move.
Joe,
would you let me play a video for you to
show you some of the dancing and Cuba?
Sure.
When women dancing Cuba,
they cover their pussy
because what I'm trying to do,
the whole dance is me baiting you.
It's the prettiest things you've ever
seen in your life.
It's me coming up to you with this
movement.
Like when I played it like ul,
I was getting nowhere with Joelle.
I was way before the podcast.
He was tightening up so I had a play.
They'll papinas my size and once he
heard that I could see Nigeria coming
alive.
He even got up and kicked his leg one
time,
which meant we're on because it's so
embedded in your culture,
but in Cuban dancing,
I'm coming up to you.
Every time I come up and I'll go like
this,
and you go like this.
Yeah,
you got to come and put your ass,
but the whole time you'll be covering
your pussy because on the exchange I go
to grab your pussy.
Harvey Weinstein would do phenomenal.
Here's how serious I take it.
By the way,
what is this?
Oh,
I,
I love.
I love Afro Cuban music or Latin Jazz,
so I'm hosting,
I'm curating and hosting a Latin jazz
series in New York at a bar called sync
every Thursday night,
Tj English and his Latin jazz
explosions.
So I get to choose the music,
the musicians who performed there,
and I and I host the evening.
Wow.
You do this every week?
Yeah.
What we're going to try to just keep.
Keep it going indefinitely.
That's phenomenal.
So this to you was a natural subject to
sort of engross yourself?
Well,
I had written,
I had published the book Havana
Nocturne,
which was about the mob in Cuba in the
fifties and I really got into it.
Then I made numerous trips to savannah
for extended periods.
So this book was almost like a sequel to
that.
Yeah,
it was a nice way to revisit that
culture.
Pick up the thread of that story because
this one is sort of an answer.
You get to the end and a Havana nocturne
and you ask yourself,
so then what happened?
What happened after the mafia got chased
out of Cuba?
What was their response?
How did they take it?
I want to show you this.
The Cuban dancing.
What does it say?
What's the name of the watch?
To see how everything is.
Look,
look at this.
Uh,
yeah.
Just keeps buzzing.
So it was always about navy.
Watch him move.
So talking about genes,
about what was it with your health.
See he went to grab a pussy.
So the dance,
a seduction,
seduction,
they're both there.
They're engaged in a mutual seduction.
This is a crazy dance.
Jamie,
what's the name of this?
Show it to me.
Grandma.
Say that co is the rhythm is the real
you a whole lot more.
And Ketos Ketos,
m u n e Q,
u I t o s d,
my times up times.
This is the province that.
Wow.
Watch how she grabs a pussy.
Every time he comes close
now that mute,
grab it,
grab it.
And she blocked it.
Oh yeah,
they don't fuck around.
That's hilarious.
So the drumming you're hearing and the
use of what's called the Shaker Array,
that Gord there and the chanting that's
going on that you would all,
you would hear all that in Santeria
ceremony.
Wow.
This grabbing the pussy shit is
hilarious.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
He kept trying to grab his junk to
occasionally,
occasionally.
But he's probably just checking how are
we doing down there?
See like he's grabbing it.
He's like squeezing it to see if it's
hard to say.
He's just playing with it.
He just threatened the grab and she
grabbed it.
That's hilarious.
So it's very playful.
Flirtatious.
And this is the culture there.
That's Cuba.
You know,
it's funny.
And Five.
I lived in a building in Fort Lee and
there was a Panamanian woman and she
told me that she went to Cuba twice as a
young girl and she wasn't surprised what
was going on in Cuba.
That was God's punishment.
She goes,
it was such a disgusting fucking place.
And then it was weird.
Couple of days after I'm talking to Tj,
a,
somebody on facebook.
I did a joke for my CSO special about
club 38.
The owner name was Willie Vandy,
and his claim to fame was that his
grandfather had the biggest dick in
Cuba.
I grew up with two kids that her claim
to fame.
One of them,
his dad was the best pool player in Cuba
and Americans will go down and he'd beat
the fuck out of him and pull you play.
They played Chicago eight ball whenever
Chicago.
The other.
His claim to fame was that his
grandfather was the guy in godfather two
who had the big Dick and they called him
superman and on Saturday nights at club
38 in union city.
He would on Saturdays,
he recreated and he had people come down
and it'd be like a comedy show.
$10 ticket in 200 people.
He would get some out chick tire up to
Cubans like that would play the congas
and he come out and fuck the lady and
go crazy with the biggest dick in the
world and my job fucker in public.
That was the whole thing.
I was like,
fuck,
show.
That was a public fuck show.
But it went all the way back to Cuba to
like 55,
like the name of the place was Shanghai,
the Shanghai Theater,
and the Godfather to Michael takes.
They take Michael there and all of a
sudden he goes,
I would have never found this place if
it wasn't for Johnny Ola.
And that's when Michael finds out that
he betrayed them.
So they don't show the guys that have
been simpler.
If the guy with the big Dick was also
the greatest pool player because he
could just,
Oh my God,
that would have been perfect.
So they did this article about two weeks
ago.
It's on my facebook and it's called in
search of Superman Joe Rogan.
It was the most disgusting article
rather than my life that these white
dudes went on a 50 year looking for
superman.
The legend of the guy with the big
thick.
In fact,
do vow went to Cuba,
to the location,
even though it's closed,
just to see where it was and what the
story is that us as Americans will go
down to every week.
And that was our first time to see this
big black Cuban dude.
Fuck the shit out of some poor white
chick,
you know,
yelled and screamed.
The place was sold out every night.
I mean,
the guy was a gardener.
The article is sensational if you could
find it.
It's called in search of Superman and
they is it better than superman.
But when it came out the same week that
they said,
what are you fucking crazy.
They ain't no fake.
That's real.
That's why they call him superman.
Afraid of the know.
I saw.
I saw a video of Superman when I was
researching Havana Nocturne.
Uh,
I found out that Santo traffic content
had a lawyer named Samara Ghana since
deceased.
But Samara,
Ghana used to take a lot of super eight
videos when he'd go down to Cuba.
His son,
who's currently a lawyer in Tampa told
me that he had super eight footage of
superman that his father had made in the
fifties,
superman at a private sex show.
Fucking a girl.
And I said,
oh,
I got to see that.
Could I see that?
I mean,
I think that's the only existing video
footage anywhere of Superman and he
said,
yeah,
but I'm not going to give it up.
You've got to come to Tampa and I'll
show it for you.
So I go down there.
I'll never forget.
He's a lawyer too.
He says you got to come at 6:00 after
the.
After the office closes so then we can
watch it and I get there and the
cleaning lady is still there,
so he brings me into the conference room
where he's going to show me the family.
We got to sit there and wait until the
cleaning lady's done because he didn't
want to put this film all the while.
The cleaning ladies in the room,
so he puts it on the plate.
Stuff is completely empty and he shows
me this footage and his father had
scored it to like Wagner or beethoven
like triumph and classical music and
it's.
It's at a private show.
It's in somebody's home.
They had private sex salons in Havana
where you'd go to like some rich
person's house.
You'd pay some money,
you had cocktails,
and then someone had clap at a certain
time and you knew that was time for the
show and everyone would sit down and
superman would come out and he,
he,
he fucked this,
a Cuban woman who was,
who was small,
he was begging,
she was small and he's banging her from
every conceivable angle.
It was the least sexy thing you've ever
seen in your life.
I mean,
it looked like a,
it looked like some kind of torture
really.
Uh,
and that was it.
And this guy had this footage,
which is probably worth a lot of money.
Big was the Dick.
The Dick was big.
It wasn't.
No,
I say that because it wasn't like,
it wasn't a,
I'm not sure it was even the biggest
stick I've ever seen.
I mean,
it was bigger than my dad's.
Bigger than normal.
It was bigger than the guys today.
It's almost like athletes,
like if you go back and look at when Jim
Brown was playing football,
he was very impressive.
But was he Herschel Walker?
You know what I'm saying?
Like athletes have today's era or
different.
And if you go back and look at John
Holmes,
yeah,
he had a big Dick,
but was it Lexington steel,
you know,
like these guys have bigger dicks now.
But the people on the board vets people
are growing.
The thing that freaked me out of the
human species is advancing fancy.
But then that about Santo that I enjoyed
from your first book event in October
and I wanted to tell Joe to stories that
one time Kennedy went to cast a Cuba as
a senator and they were having some type
of meeting but fucking Kennedy can focus
right?
And that they like,
what the fuck is wrong with him in St
Louis for Cathy goes,
I know exactly what's wrong.
Come on.
And they tapped him on the shoulder and
they bring them in a room.
He's embellishing this a little is
better.
This is what I remember I read and that
I guess Santo,
he's sic them onto women candidates
while he set up a.
They filmed it.
He said no,
they didn't film it.
They wish they wish they had filmed
that.
They said they set him up in a room with
a two way mirror and they watched it
happening and then one of them turned
the other and said,
Shit,
we should've filmed this.
This would make great blackmail
material.
Right?
Like,
Santo is kind of a freak.
JFK,
the freakiest the freaks,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
but you got to keep in mind he wasn't
married.
He was a young senator.
He used to get this senator from Florida
named George Smathers and the two of
them would go down to Havana and this
was around 1955,
56 when the whole thing was in its
heyday.
And that was a big part of a van,
uh,
politicians and businessmen with going
junkets to Havana,
like,
you know,
paid for by the company,
weekend retreat,
go to Havana.
And they'd go to the Shanghai theater
and they have Tris,
sexual Triste,
and they'd go crazy.
And it was out of sight,
out of mind.
It was the original,
you know,
what happens in Havana,
stays
in van.
It was all different country wasn't
going to make the newspapers.
So they go there and they'd rub elbows
with Santa traffic content in Meyer
Lansky and they loved it.
It was exciting.
It wouldn't.
It wouldn't do them any damage back
home.
No.
It's amazing.
When my mother died in [inaudible] 79
and whenever I did something like if I
call my head differently or if I wore
like a orange shirt,
my mom will go,
what are you fucking rock Hudson?
And I go,
what the fuck are you talking about rock
Hudson,
you know,
one day I asked,
why do you always call me a rock Hudson?
And she goes,
because rock Hudson,
I don't money go.
And I go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
She told me she died in [inaudible] 79.
My Mom told me in 1978 flat out to my
face that fucking he was gay as could
be.
And I'm like,
you don't want.
I've heard I'm sick and tired of you
fucking Cubans because Cubans,
like they used to tell me when I was a
kid that they smacked Bruce Lee and Cuba
one time that he went down there talking
shit.
And one of my uncles smack them in the
Cubans ally to you just to fucking fuck
with you.
So I thought my mother was fucking me.
She's like a rock concert is as gay as a
$3 bill.
And I go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
She goes,
I mean,
what I'm talking about right when I was
a little girl,
Rock Katrina would come to Cuba and we
would all go to the hotel.
You like when Michael Jackson goes to a
hotel,
come outside and they clapped and he
shook the kid outside the window.
We would be out there like waiting to
see rock coaching.
But the hotel guy would tell us he was
up there in a room with a man and I
would go,
Ma,
are you fucking crazy?
Like I didn't believe her.
My mother died in [inaudible] 79 85
rockets and comes on.
Says he's gay.
Like Campbell was just a hiding place
for people.
Did your mother know that the Marlon
Brando was fucking Richard Pryor?
No.
I found out from this article,
if we will have scrolled down a little
bit,
it says it,
that they asked his neighbors and the
neighbors were like,
no,
he was bisexual and his number one guy
that was known every time he came to
Cuba was Marlon Brando.
He was Marlon Brando was walking there
with to showgirls and then him and
fucking superman would leave by
themselves.
Well,
Brando loved the music he played,
but he was really into it.
Well,
Pryor's wife was saying that back then,
they were doing so much coke that
everybody just fucked everybody.
Everybody that's so crazy.
He couldn't make Jack Fuck somebody like
David Garrison.
That was one of the Mick Jagger's wife
said she caught David Bowie in bed with
Mick Jagger.
Know a lot of coke,
but I never wanted to fuck you up the
ass Joe Rogan.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I never did a lot of.
Whenever I want to fuck another guy in
the,
in the story Brando who is bisexual took
off with superman,
ditching the dancers.
So Superman was a bisexual too.
In fact,
I heard he had died of gangrene.
Gangrene,
yeah.
And here it says infected.
Yeah.
He died with a lover from sex.
Oh,
he slept around but gangrene from sex.
How hard you got to fuck to get
gangrene.
Maybe.
Fuck this chick that got shot in the
ass.
He might've fucked animals.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Dirty Bro.
Cuba was dirty.
It was dirty.
Oh Gee.
Let me say something else that's
another,
that whole society that he hasn't
touched in on that I know he knows
about.
And that's the Aba Society.
What's the requirement?
That's a complete.
That's the,
that's the Brotherhood of men in Cuba.
You will see.
So as you see them at mcguire,
you know you're dealing with them.
Doesn't talk that day.
The whole goal.
They don't.
What does that mean?
Like I fuck with you.
A couple of years ago you were living in
Colorado and I saw a kid with a balloon
and I call you balloons and we,
me and Eddie,
you come up to,
I call him his nickname.
You got a different situation.
It'll pull you aside and go,
I don't know you and don't you ever
fucking call me that outside the circle
again and when they get mad at you,
okay to prove their manhood,
they beat you.
Throw you on the floor,
pull your pants down and slice your ass
with a straight razor.
That's the worst fucking mad one.
Did that to two or three people.
My mother's wake guy couldn't come in
because one,
it's sliced his ass.
I'm like,
oh no.
This guy took me to baseball games.
One,
get the fuck out.
He stand.
That's their thing.
They only pussy.
They can't be in a room if another man
is gay in the room.
Wow.
Oh yeah,
but guess what?
Your Romero.
Tomi,
it's sold dissolved.
Now that this gay man and I bought 50
years ago,
bro,
Bro.
Some people would call that advanced
joey.
That's progress.
What's that?
That now there's getting.
Well,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
no.
It's the surprise.
They had gay man,
but 50 years ago one of that went to her
room.
You had to be on your best behavior.
They don't speak Spanish.
They have their own line.
They have their own language.
Oh,
I know it.
Wait a minute.
They have their own language.
That's the wrong way.
Which in Spanish it's a.
it's like a Patois.
It's like a patois based on African
Monina and I said it.
It had some Spanish.
When call you Monina.
That's my brother and that thing.
What's the Organization of this group?
I mean is it is.
It shows that a long shore man,
that the man of Cuba,
they don't even eat pussy.
That's such a man,
but they.
And they can fuck other men and other
men could suck.
They're begging.
They're big in prison systems.
They got pregnant system.
They can fuck other men.
Oh yeah,
I can.
I can pick you out and go joe,
you're no longer joe or Josephina will
get a wig and put lipstick on.
Pining away and I'll fuck you in the ass
and you're going to suck my dick.
Don't you fucking think you're going to
fucking kiss me and touch?
Yeah,
and they beat you.
You shut up.
You fucking whore.
You can find somebody else,
but you can't be fucked.
Fucked by another man.
That's for if a man wants to suck your
Dick Slums.
I remember one night but quite used to
tell me a guy sucked my big one time
when ice cubes in his mouth.
It was tremendous.
I'm,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Well,
that was the fourth grade I was
surrounded with.
You say hello is certain way.
I'll show you a video.
How do you spell it?
A,
b,
u k,
you hear it?
It may be a k,
u l what is it?
Pulling up.
There's a bunch of hair on youtube.
I'll show you the dance one is the one
you have to see how they dance.
How they move about quite you,
ruble,
whatever.
No,
no,
no.
This is the second one.
Go to that second one.
Hour long
and so these are just serious dudes.
They just put in and then put in y o r u
Ba and let me tell you what.
See what comes up.
It's also African base also after the
musical elements right there.
Right there.
There you go.
Okay.
Let me show you what it is.
And they're all dressed in white.
They're all dressed in white,
still dressed in white.
No women allowed.
No nothing.
Place them in this,
Jamie,
so we could hear it.
No women.
No,
no.
This woman is second.
A woman named will will dance.
So you see the woman on the road?
Yeah.
I'll see how the guy shows up.
That's an Aba.
Look at this bucket.
Beauty.
The colors are white and red,
right?
You will see red.
That's the guy that's the there.
The take the tin man from the window.
Was there the,
you know,
just saying that could get a break.
They're going to salute with your elbow.
Hit him back.
Get a bad you.
You,
you could suffer like this.
Making fun of making fun of it.
Wow.
If I see him like that's how I do like
this,
don't let me know.
But you touch elbows.
Touch,
bow.
Wow.
And now there's actually gay men.
Now it's diluted so much.
It's been diluted over the years.
But when I met Juan and Leo,
they were two.
Ob was a Taco tico or Latin band,
not the cube.
That the Conga player,
the singer.
He was about quarterly.
So if you were,
you just,
there was a code way.
You've very manly code.
I come over here,
there's a gay man and he I call you out
of the room like,
Oh,
do me a favor.
Get that motherfucker out of the room.
Or if not,
you can't talk to them.
You can approach them a certain way.
Cuba experienced a lot of progressive
ideology.
Like is it.
If they changed it,
it's very progressive
thoughts.
What's caused this because they really
didn't progress changing thing from.
Yeah,
but their progress.
I mean they are so isolated.
They didn't have the Internet,
right?
They don't have the Internet.
No,
no.
I think certain places and they're
getting it now.
I think certain places.
Yeah,
he can get it here and there.
It's not great.
It's frustrating when you go there
because he can't.
What's what's Nice is you go to Havana
and you kind of disengage from modern
technology.
I love it.
I mean you couldn't live there because
he can't really do business there,
but you just kind of disengaged from.
And is it easy to travel there now as
far as flights in America?
Just legal like a motherfucker like
hilarious.
I remember when I was a kid,
like if you had a Cuban cigar,
I was like a big deal.
I don't tell anybody we got Cubans.
Well that's still,
that's still illegal.
Some of them,
the embargo still exists.
Yeah.
But you could have some cigars.
You're allowed to have some Cuban
cigars.
Right.
You ever see if you,
uh,
what is the amount of.
I think you're allowed to have like 10.
You can't bring them back.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You can't sell them here or if you can
sell them here,
you can't sell a lot.
Something like that.
Now I'm happy rose's book because a,
I knew the story was out there.
Joe.
I like,
we haven't even touched.
Like I was raised by Omega seven guy.
Like he grew up with my father.
So I told Joey when I first met him and
I was sort of almost done with this
book.
I said,
when you read it,
you're going to need to sit down because
for a guy like him,
he knew a lot and I knew he would come
across names that he knew,
but there's no way you could have been
part of this and known the whole thing
right now.
Right.
So you,
you like,
you knew who he was.
You knew he was back.
He didn't know it was a professional
assassin for Omega seven.
I knew todd that you killed.
My mother warned me.
My mother used to go,
when he picks you up at school,
please don't get in the car with them
because it's going to get shot one day
and I don't want to interrupt people.
New Battle.
And they knew some things about him,
but they didn't know no one who was part
of it.
They thought they knew the whole story,
but there's no way you couldn't.
You couldn't know.
It blew my fucking mind.
I went to a dance with my daughter and I
came home and the book was waiting for
me.
You know,
Amazon drops it off in front of the
house and they had ripped it and there
was other kids,
other moms with my wife and I don't like
to do put it in my office.
I want to open that.
I saw Dorothy and Mancini and my fucking
knee dropped like it had hit me.
He kept texting me as you were reading
at 12:00 at night and I go,
you have no idea,
but I didn't know that this guy used to
go away every six months and his wife
was tight.
You know the story I told you about.
My mom would play cards and then I would
put tidy whities honors dance for the
women of shots of Tequila and make me
dance.
Nina was in that
book.
Nina is in that book.
When my mother died,
I gave Nina my dog.
I couldn't take that dog,
so I used to go to Nina's house on 51st
street and cry in the dog house like
this is my dog.
So soon as I saw it,
I knew he was onto something because
dorothy was my father's friend and he
was type of guy that would come visit me
every week just because he was my
father's friend and give me 50 bucks and
take me to the city and get haircuts.
But his claim to fame was in the seventh
grade.
My mother told him,
I don't know what I'm going to do with
them.
He's got some fucking girlfriend.
He won't even talk to me.
This guy came to my house and gave me a
capsule and right in front of me he
filled it up with coke and he goes,
let me tell you something.
Seventh grade,
seventh grade,
he goes,
next time this girl comes over here,
your sprinklers,
coke on a pussy and you look at.
And I'm like,
I didn't even like a pussy that I had
outside of genes.
That coke capsule was in my drawer for
like a year,
like in the back of my nightstand,
right?
I didn't,
you know,
I wasn't at,
it wasn't a drug,
nothing.
And One night my mom came home with
three cocktails and then she's like,
I got fucking news today from topic that
he gave you cocaine.
Where the fuck is I go to my drawer,
I didn't use it.
She fucking smack me.
She goes,
don't you ever fucking thing drugs?
And then she went and did it.
She went and did the blast.
But that guy,
when I was in the seventh grade,
gave me a capsule of wow and said put it
on her pussy or drive a fucking crazy.
Like that's how that meant that he was
the text.
I remember getting from you as you were
reading the book.
I was getting every,
every,
every 30 minutes or so I'd get a text
from him and be another name like I
can't believe you have this name.
Finally the last one was the texts said
Naynay Cordero with an exclamation mark
and a comment and said,
you bad motherfucker.
He couldn't believe some of the names
that were in there.
And I know that he must have been
emotional.
I said,
this is going to be tonight.
I was crying because
that was two banks.
When I was growing up,
there was Raleigh,
Amea Alito,
and there were partners with child
Miguelito.
People used to goof on him.
He had a pigeon toe and they would go on
them in front of my mother and go,
you know,
he could be Coco's father,
so mega lethal always duped me 100 bucks
and they're writing them,
but he had a Puerto Rican white,
but his name was Martin Marlana.
That was fucking hot and I guess the
name mark has had an affair with her and
he went in.
The name mark has was the barber.
Yeah.
And when I was a kid I remember someone
made a lethal shot and naked railroad
and the foot.
He walked right into the bar and that's
joe it big and become the wild west.
Yeah,
like union city had become.
If I shot Jamie,
ain't no.
The only person who didn't come after me
as Joe.
You know what I'm saying?
Like there's no cops.
Wow.
There was no cops involved and it's like
that today.
Still.
I don't know about.
No,
no,
no.
This was the seventies when still
corruption.
Oh yeah.
They robbed from fucking everything.
They just went.
I went home last week.
There was problems with Doug Burgum
right when I was home.
I stayed in edgewater,
so I didn't even go up there.
When the book came out,
I got a call from battles.
Long time lawyer,
a guy named Jack Blumenfeld.
Wonderful Guy.
Interviewed him numerous times for the
book,
new battle as well as anybody a defended
him in a number of different cases over
the years.
I knew a lot about him.
Uh,
I sent the book to him.
He called me.
I don't know him that well,
so he was a little stiff and first we
corrected some factual things in the
manuscript and then he got real quiet.
He said,
you know,
this was very,
it was very emotional for me to read
this book.
He said,
cause just all kinds of things kept
flooding back.
You would use a name or you describe an
incident and all of a sudden it would
flood my memory.
Same thing that was happening to you
when you read it,
the little detail would go,
oh my God,
it was almost like an outer body
experience and that's the power.
That's the power of literature,
man.
That's the power of like losing yourself
in a book to where it engages your
memory and your imagination that you're
almost reliving it as you're reading and
you talk about 39 slash 11 Kennedy
Boulevard,
the home of Charlie's project,
only basketball games.
I went into those projects.
I used to go there at seven in the
morning and shoot 300 jump shots because
there'd be nobody there.
So imagine you're reading a book and you
come across that address in.
It reminds you of what he's saying.
It was down the block,
up the block,
down the block was a bond named Bernice
in north Bergen for years or you have to
have.
You ran out of beer at five in the
morning.
You went to earnings and you're pounding
on the door and they would go,
what the fuck?
You want?
I want beer,
or I write,
what do you want me to get?
Three,
eight packs.
I right,
you should have said so what do you,
when you getting emotional for you can
be testing already would sell you
business and there was the coldest beer
in town.
That was his reputation when we were in
high school.
Five in the morning early.
Open up you fucking SPEC.
Fuck you better open up and you better
at least one full cases.
Now I want to get the fuck.
He would always say the two,
but I grew up in those projects.
Not a,
I didn't live there.
I don't know how many times I went there
to play basketball with him and Ernie
was probably a personal friend of the
mayor's already.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
You know what I mean?
That's everything was connected.
Joe and I both know Joe doesn't remember
about who was running north Bergen at
the time and like I said,
when my,
when my I became,
I fell into that house.
So where they,
they got his kids.
I got.
They were really talents.
So do you understand like if I went to
your house,
whatever the girls get I.
Who does that anymore?
They got a motorcycle.
I got an Indian motorcycle if they went
to Montauk for the weekend and I got the
Montauk for the weekend.
If they got a no show job,
I got a little short job.
I remember having a no show job in Irish
man when I was like in the seventh
grade.
The Janet is hated me because that
would,
that would get that and have all the
desk on top of Shit and they'd be
buffing floors,
not just walk past and will get my $80
check and they're like,
are you ever going to do anything?
I'm gonna combine though.
I do what I want.
I knew you were connected.
I knew I do not want to call my boss.
I did whatever I wanted to.
Wow.
So listen,
let's wrap this up.
This book is out right now,
the corporation,
Tj English,
and like I said,
the Westies is a fucking great book.
Once you get done with this book,
go buy that book to Tj.
Thank you very much.
My place is great.
I can't wait to read this.
Thanks for having me.
Is really fun.
Podcast to an amazing,
amazing stuff.
All right,
that's it.